(guitar music)
What does it take?
What is actually required to pursue an audacious goal?
(upbeat guitar music)
To never ever give up on your dream, no matter the odds,
no matter the obstacles.
The answer is unwavering conviction.
It's super human courage,
which are topics explored in today's conversation
with my friend Sacha Gervasi a writer, a filmmaker,
and the documentarian behind ""Anvil The Story of Anvil,"
which is this unlikely, can you even believe this is real?
Spinal Tap narrative about an unlikely eighties metal band
who never quite made it, but refused to give up,
whose protagonist Lips Kudlow and Robb Reiner
joined today's conversation.
Like literally these guys were gonna
turn the music world upside down.
This self-financed indie, much like the Bandit portrays,
was almost never seen by anyone.
As big as an influence as they had on everybody.
Everybody just sort of ripped 'em off
and then sort of just left him for dead.
But against all odds, this film becomes a cult classic.
It's now lauded as one of the greatest rock and roll
documentaries of all time and also quite ironically ended up
giving the band the break they'd always been longing for.
Then in another twist of unlikely favor during the pandemic,
the documentary was discovered by a whole new generation of
young people and in unprecedented fashion is now being
re-released 13 years after it first premiered
in 200 theaters across the United States this week
and later rolling out across Europe and beyond.
Even if you have zero interest in heavy metal music,
you are gonna love this film, I know it.
I encourage all of you to check it out in the theater.
And I also think they're gonna love this conversation
because Sacha is unbelievably entertaining.
He is a truly gifted storyteller.
His "Anvil" protagonist Lips and Robb
are also very endearing individuals.
They're extremely earnest and dare I go so far as to say
that Lips just might be the self-help guru
you never knew you needed.
So please click that subscribe button,
leave your thoughts below in the comments section
and enjoy this at times a little bit insane
and off the rails conversation with filmmaker Sacha Gervasi
and Robb Reiner and Lips Kudlow of "Anvil".
This is a celebration.
The gang is here.
We got Sacha, we got Rob, we got Lips.
Everybody is in the house.
As nice as Gomez again.
My for this is that
I'm gonna be so bold as to say that this
will be the Definitive "Anvil" podcast.
What do you think Sacha ?
I'm so thrilled a prospect.
I'm just so happy 'cause these guys just flew in
from Toronto late last night
and we've been hanging out all morning and
as with, as always is with us,
it's just like going back to when I was 15,
nothing has changed, right?
We were talking about the original "Anvil" Road crew a few
minutes ago, which was me, Brick Vegas, Spider Jetro,
and me, my "Anvil" nickname Was tea Bag-
And Strange,
And Strange.
Strange was another guy who,
I'm in tour later, I haven't, last time I saw him was on a,
a tour of Canadian hockey arenas in 1985.
But I FaceTime was strange later.
So it's just this history that just continues to evolve.
It never seems to stop. Yeah.
Well I think we need to contextualize all of this.
So I think it would be great if we just start at the
beginning with Sacha,
your kind of first introduction to these guys and kind of
how everything unfolded from that.
Well, the first introduction to these guys
was literally on, there was a,
a magazine similar to Rolling Stone in the UK called Sounds
and Sounds was the rock heavy metal kind of music paper.
NME was the kind of poncy, fancy kind of poses paper,
but Sounds was like the Real People, Red Sounds.
And I think it was April the sixth, 1982,
I went to my local news agent in St. John's Word
on Abbey Road and I saw the cover of Sounds and it said,
it literally was a photo of a man dressed head to toe
in bondage gear, holding a chainsaw and clutching
a dildo between his teeth.
And it said, "Anvil" is coming.
And I thought, I have no idea who the fucking band is.
I like this band and the reason I like them was,
this is really gonna off my mother.
This is just gonna really upset her because my mother had
gone to JU and was a concert pianist and a classical pianist
and wanted me to play piano.
And we were kind of arguing and I thought, Yeah,
I'm gonna get into Metal. And anyway, so I bought.
You're 15?
I was 14 and a half.
15, yeah at this point.
And I'd already gone out to shows, you know,
like most teenagers, you know,
the parents have no idea what they were doing.
But I was like going, I was like leaving at 13 and a half.
I would go downtown to the marquee on Hol Street.
That club was very famous because Hendrix and The Doors and
all these different people had played at the marquee
in the sixties, but by the early eighties it was like the,
the center of something called the New Wave
of British Heavy Metal,
which had a beautiful acronym NABHM that was,
that was what it was.
And so I was a young fan who would go down and I would see
Iron Maiden and I would see Def Leppard and all these bands.
Like I remember seeing Randy California from Spirit
and all these crazy bands and I would slip out at night.
My mum had no idea I was going there.
Anyway, so in the Sounds interview,
I suddenly learned about
this heavy Canadian band from Toronto.
And ironically my mother's family had been from Toronto,
so there was already an instant connection.
And they had this record that was already a legend before
anyone had even heard it.
It was called Metal on Metal.
And it was literally,
the front cover was a buzz saw Soaring an anvil in half,
I thought, could it be more metal?
And it was called Metal on Metal.
And I just absolutely had to get the album.
I got the album.
It was astonishing. It was so heavy.
There was stuff I hadn't really heard before, particularly.
There was a song called "March of the Crabs".
There was a song called 666 where it was really the first
time I had heard thrash metal played at such a ferociously
intense volume and rate.
And the musicianship was extraordinary,
Lips' voice was growling.
And like for me, the thing that really stuck,
stuck out because I was an aspiring drummer,
'cause you know, my mother said,
"You know, you should learn classical piano".
And I was, but I thought, you know what,
what's really gonna her off is
I'm gonna be a heavy metal drummer.
So then Robb Reiner came into my life and I would listen to
Robb play these things and I just could not,
I was just like blown away by his drumming.
I'd never heard any drummer as heavy as Rob.
I'd heard a lot of amazing people like Ginger Baker and
Karma and (indistinct) and all these great, you know,
fantastic dramas, Steve Gad obviously genius,
but no one with the heaviness of Robb Reiner.
And so when I discovered that they were gonna play at the
Marquee in September, 1982, so I got the sounds in April,
I bought the record that month and through the whole
of the summer of 1982,
Anvil's Medal on Metal was like blaring at top volume
through my house, my mother was going out of her mind.
And this is a moment in which I suspect
most of your peers are into Bowie.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, that was the other thing was like, this is,
I was at a school where everyone was like into the doors and
Bowie in the Stooges, and like,
I'm the loser walking across schoolyard in like black leg
warmers with like my rush waist coat and like just I was,
everyone gave me so much shit.
And then I thought, you know what?
Fuck them man. I'm the punk.
I'm the guy getting all the abuse.
And I was like,
and then I said to my friend who was like Jake,
who was like into kind of punk and the Clash and everything.
I said, you all dress the same.
You've all got the trousers in the same hair and fuck you,
I'm the punk.
So like, the more they attack me,
the more metal I became and I would start going to these
shows and I went to a, you know, a board,
a sort of public boarding school in England
called Westminster.
And so I was very much like the,
the ugly Duckling at that school by a very, very long way.
And so the more defiantly kind of attacked I was,
the more defiantly metal I became.
And I discovered that Anvil was playing at the Marquee.
And so I decided to go and I was so fucking lucky
because I went to see the band
and literally Lips flew out of the
changing room at the back clutching a dildo,
and he played his flying V and I mean, like,
you gotta sound with a bunch of teenage boys,
we'd never seen or heard anything like this, right?
He had the chainsaw, Robb was like,
you couldn't even see his face.
His hair was like,
he would do this move, which I call tumbling boulders,
where you just couldn't even see how his hands were moving.
I was just like,
it was like any person who remembers their first show
where their face was melted off,
it was like my whole head was melted off.
I was like,
anyway, I was like, and that place was packed.
And later, years later I discovered so many bands
that became bands were also there that night.
So many really interesting people,
like members of Def Leppard, like Jonas Ackland,
the video director and you know, every, you know,
members of the Tigers of Pantang.
And that moment was a huge moment in my life and it was also
a huge moment for "Anvil" and I was desperate to meet them.
And so what happened was I went in the long line
and there were these two security guys, right?
And anyway,
this guy called Gary Barden was the lead singer
of the Michael Schenker group.
And he was in an argument with the bouncer with his
girlfriend to get his girlfriend backstage
to meet Anvil, right?
And I just took advantage of the moment and I slipped in.
So they, the security guy was
trying to get Michael Shanker's singer to stay away.
And I just kind of got in behind them
and I literally walked in
and they were members of Iron Maiden,
members of Def Leppard like all my heroes were in that room,
congratulating this band.
And I was just like,
fuck, I'm the youngest person in here by like,
at least five to 10 years.
And I went right up to Anvil,
I went right up to Robb and to Lips, and I said,
"I am your number one fan in England.
My name is Sacha and I am just",
and I started asking Robb questions about the drums,
and I just was so.
No, we were both going like, this kid,
it's a kid and he knows everything,
He knows more than anybody else in this that's here.
He, he had a special magic about him.
That is what I remember. And we invited him in.
He said, "Well, I"-
I said like on tag team between the,
the mid and the verse when you do this flip thing with,
you know,
I was talking to Robb technically about what he was doing,
and I was, I had millions of questions.
I was like, how do you do that?
And are you using both feet or you doing whatever?
And then I was asking Lips about, you know,
how they work together as a band.
And so I had tons of questions.
Now the first thing I noticed about Anvil
was I'm some 15 year old no one kid, right?
And they were talking to me and there were Joe Elliott and
whoever of Def Leppard there was members of Motorhead,
fast Eddie Clark, there were like massive mega people.
And these two guys were interested in what their fan
had to say.
And I was just like, Wow. I couldn't believe it.
The truth was that none of these people,
none of the other people even knew our songs.
They don't own our records.
They don't know the songs they just heard.
They're just, they're ligging the moment, right, basically-
And you're like, we're gonna talk to this kid,
this kid's into it.
It's like a crazy sliding doors moment.
Like, had you not done the run around with the Bouncer?
Yeah. Oh yeah.
And I was so happy.
I was so happy that Gary Barden was in love with,
with this woman and had to get her in,
or he wasn't coming in.
But it was every rockstar,
every metal and Hard Rock person at that time was
at that show and was absolutely blown away.
And I was just the lucky one who got in.
And as it turned out, I said, "You know, look,
I just wanna let you know I'm, I'm offering my services.
I'll be your tour guide, I don't care".
And they were laughing and they were like, Well, I said,
"How many times have you been to London?"
And they said, "Well, we've never been here before".
And I said, "Great, I'm gonna show you around".
So I agree to meet you-
Ask us where hotel we were at, where we were,
and we showed up.
So the next day I them to the Houses of Parliament,
the tape gallery introduced them to Turner.
You know, I took them all over the,
the sites of London and it was so fun.
I remember being on the Tube, getting off the tube with,
with all of you.
And the Tube driver was an "Anvil" fan,
do you remember?
And he like, I remember he honked the car
and he was like, metal.
And I was like,
Anvil was like happening in London and I felt so privileged
that I'm like their fan, right?
You happened to meet them. So I take them everywhere.
The best part was I took them back to number 54 Aey Road
where I grew up in London.
I took them back and my mother answered the door that was,
and she saw.
Danny Ma.
Yeah.
It was like, no, it was like,
and the nightmare scenario because I'd played that album all
summer and she told me to take it away.
And she was just like, well, she was going out of her mind.
So when I showed up with Anvil, she looked at me,
she looked at them and then she said,
"You've got 10 minutes".
And she disappeared upstairs.
And I was like,
I brought them into my room and it was really weird because
I was, you know, the biggest Anvil fan.
And then they walked into my bedroom,
I got posters of metal or metal
all over my walls and everything.
And so they were so sweet with me and I just felt like
how lucky it is to be able to meet your heroes
and then to have time with them
and they actually even gave a to listen to you?
It was like really notable.
And then, anyway, so at the end of the couple days,
and they were staying at the Columbia Hotel
and I went to hang out with them
and then I got to know the guys from
Twisted Sister who I also know the,
the those guys and D Snyder and AJ Peril and all those guys.
And at the end of the two or three days we kind of really,
well, you know, I was like so happy that they, you know,
were being nice to me and Lips and Robb said, 'Hey, hey,
what are you doing next summer?"
And I said, "Well, you know,
I'm at school and then I'll probably be on school holidays".
I was like 14 and a half at that point or 15.
And they said,
"Do you want to come and be a roadie on our tour?"
And I was like, "Are you fucking kidding me?"
So basically my mom and my father split up on,
my dad was living in New York,
he went to the United Nations and I said to my mother, Look,
I really want to go see my dad for this summer.
She was like shocked.
Like, why do you wanna see your father?
I was like, Well, you know,
I think it's time we need to tour anyway,
so I totally an excuse to get a ticket to New York.
And I flew to New York the following summer
and I said to my dad, Look, if I'm being really honest,
the reason I'm here is because Anvil,
this mega heavy Canadian thrash metal band has asked me to
come on tour as as the drum roadie.
And so my dad, who you know was, you know,
he worked for John F. Kennedy, you know,
he was an economist, he taught at Oxford, you know,
he was like, I showed him the photos,
he was like fucking horrified.
I said, "Dad, it's really important to me.
Please can I just please go on tour with Anvil?"
And he said, "I have to meet them, I'll only do do it".
And so he drove me up to Albany where I joined the tour and
he said, "I'm gonna go and talk to Lips and Robb".
And he was wearing his three piece suit, you know, and he,
he talked to Lips and Robb
and I don't quite know what was said.
I think it was something along the lines
of just keeping away.
You're gonna watch out for my son,
that he doesn't get in trouble here
and you guys are not-
It's been like a concerned parent.
Right?
Yeah.
But you all understand my father was,
is looking at Lips and Robb at, you know,
and you know the album with him.
And it's, and he is like an Oxford academic and it's like,
you know, but whatever happened between them,
my dad came out and he said,
"I actually think they're okay
and you can go for three weeks".
And I was just,
I was so overwhelmed with joy that I was able
to go on the road with these guys.
And you and you remember that encounter?
And it, I thought it was so weird that this...
This parenting thing's happening.
The way that, I mean,
it wasn't the first inter interaction that we had
with Sacha's parents that we obviously knew his mom too.
And when they, when he says they knew my mom,
what happened was, I just-
When he showed up at the hotel in England,
the phone rings in our room and she goes,
I pick up the phone and she goes, "Hello,
I'm Sacha Gervasi's mother, is my son there?"
And I go, "Yes, hold on, it's for you".
And it was my mom had tracked me down.
The first thing. So I go, How did you find me?
That's true.
And what had happened was I'd called a minicab company and
she found and tracked where they were,
and then she called me and then she came anyway,
so she came to the hotel room and just like said,
"Stay right there".
And she literally pulled me out by my ear and said,
"You are not hanging out with these people".
And I could hear her screaming, walking down the hallway.
She was like,
"You've gotta stay away from these people.
They're bad news and you are a well educated good boy.
You can't hang out with a guy who wears bondage harnesses
and plays guitar with a dildo, it's outrageous".
And you know,
it was a real scene that happened all the time.
Anyway, so yeah.
So then my dad was the other parent who,
and but my dad, I think whatever, for whatever reason,
he really loved, He just thought, Okay,
these guys are cool and I think he made you promise to keep
away from alcohol and drugs and-
Yeah, he said, yeah, he said,
"Tell me, just make sure that he doesn't go near anything
that's gonna get him in trouble".
I said, "Don't worry about it".
He, as far as I'm concerned,
he's not gonna see any wrongdoings not be while he is my-
And then cut to the tour.
And that's often why I was locked into the tour bus.
So I was also locked on the tour.
Well, there were things going on he never saw.
You never saw.
You did protect him.
No, totally.
Yeah. But you know what, there was a kid,
you don't let a kid walk into a middle of a,
some squirrly having an orgy.
No, I don't.
Dave Allison, who was, yeah, so what, So,
but what happened was my dad came back and he said,
'those guys gave me,
gave me their word and I believe them
so you can go for three weeks'.
And I just had, it was like,
it was an extraordinary experience
to be out on the road with this band.
You know, I sat behind Robb Reiner every night.
I helped build his drum kit.
I watched him play like as he was playing like, you know,
Mothra or metal or metal or 666 or whatever,
he would do some crazy lick
that I'd asked about when we first met.
And he would turn around to me and go,
"You will never be able to do that".
It was like, but I would pick up this minute, you know,
that, that look, that.
And I, and I used to enjoy doing that.
Go, Okay, Sacha here's one that you're,
this one's a good one, watch this.
And then I'd give that look like, see.
And I was right behind him.
And you gotta understand that at that time there were all
these young, you know, metal fans like me.
You know, and who I went into the show, you know,
was guy called Scott Ian,
who later went on to form Anthrax and La Orrick who was,
you know,
a 15 year old Danish tennis prodigy who was just getting
interested in music and so many other people that were kind
of around and just, you know,
even pre-band, we're just thinking about what to do.
I mean, millions of people.
And Jonas was in that Swedish metal band Bar Three
and then all these different.
Well that, how to hold that.
That's another,
another sort of thing that happened at the marquee at that,
at that particular time in point in the history
is two members of this band called Candle Mass from Sweden.
Were also at the show, were also.
With their friend from Bathy, which is Jonas Ackland.
They came to see us,
They take a, Jonas takes a picture of me with the two guys,
and here we are as young kids, whatever years later,
I mean like years later,
we're just previous to actually reconnecting with Sacha .
We go to do this festival in Italy and we're sitting in a,
in a bus camper,
a little camper bus kind of thing.
And there's a knock at the door and there's these two freaky
guys and there goes,
we're the guitar player and bass player
from the band Candle Mass.
We met you in 1982.
Around the same time.
And I, and I...
They're kids.
So, and I'm, I'm going, wait a minute,
these are those Swedish guys that we met on Carnegie Street.
And they're going, Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That and then all of a sudden I started,
and I start telling them about Sacha and I go,
I haven't seen this guy in years.
But that was, you're, you were with us when,
when you took us to get the bullet belts on Carnegie Street.
We bumped into these two guys from Sweden.
Who became in the massive-
Yeah. For people that don't,
Jonas Ackland becomes this super successful video director.
They're all kids in the same place.
So we all end up at the marque and we're all,
so here we are in Los Angeles after the movie,
I'm sitting there and all of a sudden I see this big tall
guy with black hair coming long black hair comes walking up
to me he goes, "Hi, I'm Jonas Ackland,
I was at your show and at the marque and in"-
With some, with so many other people.
And I go, he says, Yeah,
I was with the guys in cattle mouse.
I go, "Are you kidding me? What?"
Well, wait a minute.
That means that you know Sacha you should know Sacha .
You were all there at the same time.
That was so.
So I ran and got Sacha I go, You gotta meet this guy.
He was at the show too,
and I didn't know that Jonas Ackland was this.
Massive video director.
He was, he was, to me,
he was the guy that I,
that took the picture of the guy of us.
And I was, it was more of a, wow.
Look at this guy was at the marque too
that I'm introducing other person.
That we should was a guy called the
right Honorable Philip Harvey.
He was known as the Lord of Metal.
He was an English aristocrat who would go on safari in,
in Kenya, take his Land Rover, come back back to London.
And he, I met him through these guys 'cause-
Yeah, when we, when we did the Donington Festival
we finished the Donington Festival.
There's a guy, a freak guy standing there with a,
a denim jacket with more patches than you can fit on it.
And, and he, he's in front of a safari van.
It's like, and he comes over to us, he goes, Hi there,
you got some pretty serious denims.
Really, really fucking cool older guy. Right?
And he introduces when we were hanging out with him,
as it turns out, this is,
this is the same guy that Jimmy Hendrick
spent the last night with.
And he had, and he had this,
and he had this house in Clark's Muse.
Phil Harvey had this party house,
which was behind Mar High Street and I-
Baker Street.
And I was invited to go to this house
and I literally met the world,
like members of, I'll tell you several stories,
but he was Monica Danon,
who was Hendricks's last girlfriend was there,
there were all these incredible, I mean, I remember sitting,
he invited me over Sunday lunch one day.
I'm 15 and a half at the time, right?
And I'm sitting there at this table and suddenly this
camper van comes into the muse, right?
And the, the door slides open
and this massive cloud of weed comes out,
comes into the back door.
And he said, "Oh, this is my mate". You know?
And so he opened the back door and this guy sat down
and was smoking dope.
And like he parts his hair to smoke the dope
and it's Jimmy Page of Led Zeppelin.
And I'm sitting there at 15 like meeting
all these extraordinary people.
Not just Anvil,
but like everyone and then Monica
and then all these crazy artists.
And he knew like Dolly back in the day.
And so Phil was a character who connected us
and those parties were legendary with like,
twisted Sister and Maiden and-
It was unbelievable.
This guy got tired and he's got, you know,
when they say is served on a silver platter,
I mean served on his silver.
He came out with a silver.
A silver platter filled with every drug.
Under the, in the universe.
Would you like some, sir? It's like.
And I made sure that my mother did not track me down.
It was like.
Oh my God.
So that was the world.
It was so unexpected and crazy.
And then flash forward to many years later,
after the movie came out,
when these guys went to the classic Rock awards
and Jimmy Page of Led Zeppelin
came up to both of those guys and said,
"Thank you for doing what you do
because you keep me inspired doing what?"
And that was the-
You give us all hope.
Yeah you give us all hope.
That's what Jimmy Page said to these guys.
I was shocked when I heard all that. That's unbelievable.
I was just standing go, Did I just hear that?
Really?
From Jimmy Page?
From Jimmy Page? What?
Yeah. Like.
And he went out of his way, came right up to both of us.
It was like, wow, that is.
Yeah. The "Anvil" movie really affect,
somehow had an effect on many people.
I mean that had to be surreal after everything
that you guys have endured and the-
(indistinct chatter)
I can't tell you that that particular night at the,
at the Classic Rock Awards was for me
most earth moving moment of my life.
There wasn't anybody there that didn't actually somehow
come up and congratulate me and,
but I'm not talking about people.
I'm talking about the most famous musicians in the world.
And I'm like going what the?
I mean when we had our,
when we had our premier in New York, I remember we were.
Yeah, it was all just surreal.
'Cause we didn't know, you.
We were, we were...
Talking to Jack Bruce for Christ come on.
And Paul McCartney as well.
No, no, that's somewhere else.
Oh yeah. Somewhere else, somewhere else.
But anyway, but so I was at the,
we were at Barry Hotel and the thank you to Sch McPherson
who owns the Barry Hotel because he literally
loved the movie.
And he was like, just screen it all the time.
And we had everyone from like David Burn of Talking Heads
and all these credible people coming and just loving it
and meeting the band and doing all this stuff.
And one night we were there and Lips comes out
from having a smoke on the terrace.
And he said,
"There's this English guy and this black guy out there and
they really wanna meet you".
And anyway, so I go out and they're like
the Uber "Anvil" fans and it's
like Chris Martin and Jay-Z and Lips
had absolutely no idea who they were.
We were just...
(all laughing)
There's this, there's an English guy and a,
and a and a black guy, man.
They love the "Anvil" movie.
They had me sit down and have bought me a drink
and everything, you gotta meet these guys.
And that would just go on all the time.
And then at the,
I remember in la do you remember that whole Oh, oh,
the Dustin Hoffman thing, Oh, this incredible.
That was great.
Dustin was so cool.
Dustin often went to see the movie like three or four times.
He brought all of his kids to see it and then he came to the
premier with Ryan Gosling and all these people, right?
And he came up to the them afterwards and said,
he was talking about the Jewish aspect of the story,
which is a huge part of the film
for those who haven't seen it.
And he was talking about how he related and anyway,
so he was in floods of tears
and I was trying to get to them.
And so Lips and Robb were talking and, you know,
talking about,
because for those of you who haven't seen the film,
you know,
an important thing that was revealed actually while we were
shooting was that Robb told me that his grandfather had
unfortunately passed away.
Auschwitz and his father as a 15 year old had escaped.
And so when Robb wanted to be a heavy metal drummer,
his dad was like, Great, let's do it.
And paid for the first album, you know,
it was an extraordinary story.
And so Dustin was really relating to that.
But the best part of it was when Robb like,
was listening to him,
Dustin's crying and Rob's saying yes like that.
And then Robb sides to me and he goes,
Is that the guy from Pepeo?
And the thing was that he wasn't quite sure
and it was just Dustin completely in tears.
And that was what was great is that.
That Robb didn't know who these people were.
That just makes it all the sweeter.
Photo session here somewhere.
And and the guy, there's a,
a Canadian photographer who's freaking out
that we were there, he goes and he,
at that particular moment,
he was working with Sandra Bullock and he comes running,
he grabs Robb and I takes us
into where Sandra's getting her,
her makeup done and she meets us and all this.
And then Robb comes out and he goes,
"That's a pretty hot chick. Who is she?"
You know, that was just usual.
Anyway, that went off.
But it was, you know, it was not that, it was the,
it was the things I think that,
that have resonated for people what it's really about
and why, as you know,
why we're doing this is 'cause the movie
is being re-released after 13 years, which is quite unusual.
And so I think it's, you know what it's really about.
It's really, that's really something.
Yeah, it resonates
and it's continuing to find new audiences
and younger audiences because of the heart, right?
It's this beautiful story of what it means
to pursue your passion and not give up no matter what
in the face of all of these obstacles.
And I think audience members, myself included,
like fall in love with you guys because you're so earnest
and because it's just about the doing of it.
Like, yes, you have this dream, we're gonna be rock stars,
but irrespective of outcomes or anything like that,
like you're showing up every day, you're putting out albums,
you're doing shows and you're absolutely getting by
in order to just do the thing.
And I think that that's super inspiring because all of us,
no matter who we are,
we all have a dream or something
that we'd like to manifest in our life.
And some of us-
99% of life is being there.
You got of it.
But the showing up no matter what, you know,
is really what it's about.
We, but we don't,
we can proudly say that the band has really now
become our shitty day job.
(all laughing)
Its true.
But you know what you wish for a Rob?
No, I was, Oh, I couldn't be, I couldn't be.
It didn't have to be careful.
He's very happy with where it is.
Very happy.
Still couldn't be enough.
Yeah, exactly.
But you know, I knew-
I always say that because, you know, it's like-
There's aways room for improvement.
You're always doing, you're doing what you love.
For, not for reasons of money,
but for reasons because you love it.
I knew something special was happening,
like when we were first thinking about doing the movie
and I went to, I took, I said to Lips,
come to my uncle Marty's house
in Forest Hill on Aver Road in Toronto.
And I said, "Look, I just have this instinct,
I've gotta make this film".
And Lips broke down into tears.
And I was like, why is he crying?
Because he knew before anything happened,
what was gonna happen.
And I was like-
Yeah, I was,
I was really certain immediately-
He knew it was-
I knew, I knew, my boat just came in.
Where do you think that comes from?
What was that about that> that certainty of that?
Well, what was that about?
Part of it is because, and the failures for no reason,
I felt all along that there had to be
some kind of counter to it.
That even though that we have all this bad luck
and all this stuff, there's some reason or at,
at the end of the day, this is gonna turn around.
And I don't know why I just,
I'm was completely convinced
and what I was also convinced of,
it was going to be somebody that we met
and was a fan from a young age,
was gonna grow up and get into a,
a proper position and that's when
we're gonna get our second chance.
That's what I really,
because we missed the first chance.
The first chance came and we got involved
with the wrong people.
And at the worst time, at the worst time,
1983, everything is starting to blossom for heavy metal.
And now we fall out and we don't do a record for four years.
You're done, man.
You're roasted.
That kills, that killed all the momentum.
It's like starting all over again and it
and starting over again with way less going for you
because everything else is grown up so tall.
How are you gonna compare and how are you gonna,
how are you gonna contend now that everything and
everybody stole everything you did blind.
To the point where everybody's doing it.
So you're not gonna come across
as being the special thing anymore.
You're done, It's done.
It did its thing. You, you did-
There's a famous line in a movie "slash says it", right?
Yeah. I mean, but but those things were the realities.
But the way that I looked at it is that okay,
we missed our first opportunity, so what's gonna happen?
It's gonna happen.
Somebody where we laid the,
made a huge impression on it at a young age
is gonna grow up to the point
and get into a position of power.
Whether it's gonna be owning a record company,
I thought it was gonna be owning a record company
or something that was always in my mind.
But when I came back from that festival in Italy,
after talking to the Candle Mass guys, I get an email from,
from Sacha who, who like, I haven't spoke to in years.
Spoke to for 20 years.
It's like, you know,
last time I spoke to him is 1985 and it's 2005.
It's like hello?
Like where you been?
All those years
Yeah, but all those years
we were always wondering where Sacha went.
so from my side side, what had happened was,
and going back to the original story we were telling was
that I was into metal and then 17, 18, 19 I got into Bowie,
I got into the Stooges, I got, you know,
I kind of grew up a little bit,
but always loved Anvil and always loved metal,
but I just expanded as well.
So I loved other things and I kind of went off on my journey
and I found myself some years later in Hollywood.
And I well-
Before that though, you were a drummer.
You were the original drummer in Bush
That is correct.
Gavin Ross-
So you had a moment.
Yeah, so Gavin Ross and I had gone
to school together to two schools,
Northbridge House in Westminster.
And then, yeah, I'd, he'd,
I'd been the a founding member of that band,
which at that time was called Future Primitive,
Still a good name.
And I played on all, a lot of those songs
and all the original material from the first Bush album,
which was huge.
You know, I'd started off with them.
I was the first real drummer to play those songs.
And it was, you know, and,
and there was also other stuff going on in my personal life
for whatever reason,
I kind of left that band and I kind of then got my life
sorted out and decided to, I always wanted to be a writer,
so I became a journalist and then I was like,
well actually I really wanna make movies.
And then I found myself in UCLA film school
and then I got lucky and had a film made.
And anyway, so I had developed some something of
a Hollywood career and had a,
just a big movie made and I was sort of in 2004 or five,
I was kind of like, had had this moment.
I remember I was at, I, you know, I had this beach house,
you know,
and I was sitting at this beach house and I was like,
I got into this movie business I had,
I was sort of "successful", whatever that means.
I was successful.
Now my agents were like,
you have to go and meet Adam Sandler and you have to do all
this stuff and you're gonna be paid all this money.
And I was-
When did, when did the terminal come out?
That that was made in 2004.
Yeah, so I had,
I made a movie with Spielberg and Hanks and yeah,
so I'd done that and you know,
there was lots of opportunity,
but the opportunity to me was to make, was to make money,
you know, and I was not happy.
I was like, is this what it is?
Like this is not really,
because there were so many pressures to kind of go and do
stuff that I didn't really feel.
And I was having this really low moment when most people
would've said, you know, you should be thrilled.
And I was at a certain level, but I was also like,
I got into this business to tell stories that were really
personal and that meant something to me.
And I was thinking about how the hell am I gonna do that
rather than being part of this giant corporate machine?
Because my agents were saying, you know,
you can get XXX amount of money to do this big studio thing
and work with such and such a star.
And I just realized, my God, it's a business.
And I just was like, I was a bit of a,
I was a bit like at a crossroads and for whatever reason
"Anvil" came into my mind and I was like,
fuck what happened to "Anvil" man, because I knew, you know,
Metallica, Slayer, Anthrax,
all those bands who'd been influenced by "Anvil" and by,
you know, that whole group of bands, you know,
had gone on to become mega bands.
But what had happened to Anvil so went online
and I discovered this rinky-dink website.
Please don't be insulted if I call it rinky-dink,
but it was, you know-
That's okay.
It's a fancy Dink-
It's a one of the first ones
that had-
It's a fan site.
It was fan site.
(indistinct chatter)
Anyway so, I went on and I discovered this fan site
and I discovered that "Anvil" had just played
like at a pub in Quebec, right?
Just that weekend.
And then I discovered, oh my God,
they've done like nine other albums that I don't know.
Anyway, so I wrote to the website
and I remember writing and I,
I wrote to to Lips and I said, "Dear Lips,
I dunno if you remember me, my Anvil name was Teabag,
this is Teabag", you know, blah, blah blah, blah, blah.
I would love to just speak to you and catch up.
So I just thought, fuck they kept going,
but they're not famous and they just kept going.
And within an hour I got an email back from Lips saying,
Teabag.
What?
We thought you died or became a lawyer.
(all laughing)
That's right.
Both of those things had happened.
Yeah, those are-
I have had overdose
and I had gone to law school,
so I was like, yeah, it's roughly accurate.
So I had just like, you know, gone through some,
some crazy times and I said to Lips,
I said, "Dude, I gotta see you".
I just had this feeling talking to him again.
It was like 20 years was nothing, it was like two minutes.
And I said, "I'm gonna fly you out to LA this weekend,
would you come if I bought you a ticket?"
And so I bought him a ticket and I'll never forget,
I pulled up in my car at LAX and Lips came out and he had,
he was wearing the same Scorpions T-shirt
that he had been wearing 20 years before
when I had last seen him.
And he was so happy.
And I was like, Dude, what's happening man?
And I was thinking, God,
this has been really hard because all the bands like have
gone on to be mega and Anvil's like playing a pub in Quebec
and I'm sure it's great, but you know, this is tough.
And Lips was like, No man,
we're doing the new album and we're doing this
and we got this tour.
And it was just like, at first,
if I'm really honest, my thought was, fuck man,
this is like a bit sad.
Like you should just give this up.
But, you know, what happened was, as he started to explain,
I was so lifted by his enthusiasm and his passion
and his commitment and it was just like,
I need this person in my life right now.
Here I am with all this "success"
and I'm miserable as most people
when they get on the other side
of the curtain discover, it's like-
Well, to me he missed,
he missed all these albums.
He's saying,
We don't exist, to you, we didn't exist.
But, but to me, I've been here all along.
And then he is like, you gotta listen to this
and how about that?
And then so we started anyway,
so what happened was, I was so, like,
I just was so happy to see him and we called Robb
and I was just so,
I felt like that old feeling of my friends
and I felt this incredible feeling like this,
this has come into my life for some reason right now,
I don't quite know what the reason is,
but this has come into my life and I felt so inspired and I,
I took Lips to meet, you know, the best man at my wedding,
my mentor, you know, Steve's alien who had, you know,
written "Schindler's List" amongst many other things.
And I took Lips down to Malibu
to meet Steve and Elizabeth and I remember making coffee
with Steve and watching Lips kind of explain Anvil
to Elizabeth, who was somewhat bemused through the window.
Just like, what the fuck?
And Steve said, "Who is this guy?"
And I said, "This is my friend lips".
And he was in this band and I told him the whole story and
Steve went online and started looking up lyrics
and was like, they have a song called "Show Me Your Tits".
And I said, "Yes they do,
but it's really like funny
and they have a sense of humor, anyway".
And I told him the story that they've still going
and all the bands, they,
and he said, "You know what, there may be a,
there may be a film here".
And I said, "Really?"
He said, "Just think about it".
That hadn't even occurred to you.
That was not part of it was the motivation
or anything at that point.
It was sort of like I had an instinct, but in a,
in a strange way, Steve crystallized that instinct.
He was like, Okay, I'm, what I'm thinking is that,
But he kind of brought it out because I was so enthusiastic
and excited and it was immediately,
it was a story about just not giving up no matter what,
when most rational same people would've stopped long ago.
The indomitable spirit of being committed to your art and
being committed to your friend.
Because remember like Lips and Robb met when they were 13,
14 years old and they decided to rock together forever and
literally as we sit here today,
it's 50 years later ,they're 65 and they're still doing it.
Like how unusual and unique was that?
And that was already going.
Without making millions of dollars.
We're we're talking about Keith Richards-
Sure, doing passion.
Two guys who did it for the,
and and ultimately it's the same reasoning.
Yeah.
It is the same reasoning at heart.
There's no no different.
They got, they got super successful doing it.
I didn't get so successful doing it.
But you still did it.
But I still did it and I still do it for the same reason.
I love music, that's why I do it.
You take money as a souvenir, that's about it.
But generally you're,
you're doing it because you really love to do this.
You're driven to do it.
And I'm driven,
my thing that drives me most is I've gotta make,
I gotta put together a song
that's gonna satisfy this motherfucker.
If it can satisfy him.
Because the way that I like part of, you know,
you're growing up relationship, you know, when I,
if you understand what I mean, you have a,
a buddy that that goes out and buys everybody's record and
is like, is like the dictionary of information.
You know what I'm saying?
That's who,
that's who I'm working with is somebody
who has knowledge of everything that everybody did.
And so when when I go and bring something to the table,
he goes, I know exactly what we could do.
I got examples from this song, this song, this song.
And then before you know it because of those arrangement
ideas and with that kind of volume of knowledge,
you've got songs and matters of minutes.
So I had, so I had this instinct about.
That's what makes our writing work so well.
I had had this instinct about I gotta,
I gotta make this film.
And I thought I gotta test out this thing.
'Cause I thought initially
it was gonna be like a dramatic film.
Like I would have actors-
I mean why-
Documentary inspired and anyway,
so finally I got to the place where like,
like what am I doing?
And at the same time,
actually Aus Osborne had called me to see
if I would do his movie at Paramount.
And I was thinking about that and I was like,
Why would you hire an actor to play Aussie?
He's, you can't beat that.
Well, like why would you do it?
So I was thinking, Hmm.
And then basically I called my friend Rebecca Yello,
who's a fantastic producer and Rebecca had produced the
"Motorcycle Diaries" and "The Kite Runner"
and all these incredible movies.
She'd been a programmer at Sundance.
And I called her up and I said, "Let me tell you a story".
And so I took her to dinner and told her the story of Anvil
of this friendship with the guys who hadn't given up and
they're still going or whatever.
And she said,
"I hate Heavy metal and I have to make this movie with you.
It's absolutely great".
And so Rebecca, who literally was not,
you know, just came on board.
And I went then to and Rebecca and,
and Lips and Robb and I all met in Toronto.
She was there, I can't remember with a movie.
And we all met and Rebecca said, "Oh,
I'm gonna take you out to this restaurant."
And you know,
you got emotional at the restaurant and Rebecca said to you,
you know, what's going on?
And you said,
I delivered fish to this restaurant for eight years
and this is the first time I've eaten here.
And she just suddenly was like, Okay,
I understand what this film is.
This is a film about everyone who has to do what they gotta
do to do the thing they love.
And she was just suddenly got really on board and I was
like, Look, I'm never gonna sell this movie to anyone.
I'm gonna have to finance it.
And then there was the big decision,
I gotta get a crew together.
And I went to this terrific cameraman called Chris Seus,
who's absolutely brilliant.
And I hired Chris and I hired Matt Dennis for sound.
And we put this,
this thing and I just flew to Eastern Europe
'cause they were gonna do a tour.
And I just thought, this is now is the moment.
And I didn't know what I was doing.
I funded the whole thing myself.
It was nearly destroyed me financially
if I'm being really honest.
And multiple times we were told, just give this up,
just give it up, stop it.
And then we made the film and I started editing.
I had fantastic editors, Andrew Dickler and Jeff Renfro,
who had absolutely brilliant.
We edited on my dining room table.
It was all self-funded
and we had no idea what we were doing.
And we all stood in a circle.
I remember when we had the first cut of the movie
and we were all in my house at Mon Car
and we just kissed the DVD,
We would send it to Sundance hoping that something would
happen and they, they let us.
Well the the funniest thing was they're going, okay,
we gotta, no, let's see if we get into Sundance.
I go, What do you mean get in?
(indistinct chatter)
You got going, you're gonna take the the DVD over to the,
to the, to the people there.
And I go, well, I thought what?
They haven't seen it?
I thought, I thought it's like,
I thought it's a shoe in What do you mean.
Explain to Lips there were like 25,000 films
looking for like 20 places.
Yeah. And then I went, Oh really?
(bright upbeat music)
Prophets Walk Among Us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world is
populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people who
have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for
the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down the most
compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast to elucidate the
best of what they have to offer and to sharing the insights
gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium by which to share
their stories.
Which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book "Voicing Change Volume two"
More than Mere words on paper.
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Ritual Podcast.
The first edition of Voicing "Change"
was a beautifully rendered book
worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition by showcasing even
more of my favorite conversations in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts,
essays and stunning photography making for an exquisite
companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom of
your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact with
the life changing ideas contained within them.
"Voicing change" volume two, available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
What I remember about that time, I mean, first of all,
I remember being at the barbecue that you had at your beach
house when, when Lips when came to LA
and I remember meeting, I'm sure you don't remember that,
but I vividly remember that and I thought,
what is going on here?
I didn't understand. All my friends were like, Who is?
Well 'cause there's a very bougie situation
and then there's, you know, Lips is here.
And I was like, Who?
You were like the person I didn't know and you're like,
this is my friend Lips and you told the story
and I was like, well that's interesting.
We'll see what happens here.
But I didn't even have the idea for the movie then.
Yeah, I know.
I was just like,
this is my friend.
And then Lips told me some stuff and we talked about robo
and the band and what had happened
and all the different things.
And it was like,
there was just this reconnection between all of us
that was so surprising.
We had some, some such hilarious, I had,
I had a interview that was sent to me from,
from France and
(laughing)
we start doing this interview.
So he says, I'm bored with doing these interviews,
can you answer for me?
So I wrote all his answers for the French interview
and it was like, I wrote the most-
I was literally in,
we were literally in tears from the, that like,
there there's worse giving a fictitious story
about what happened, How did we,
how did "Anvil" get together and all this stuff.
And, and there was such unbelievable stories about squirrely
working in a cemetery.
They also asked what the full members doing.
And I said he's, you know,
he's a grave digging assistant in a certain cemetery,
(indistinct)
We were just making up as we go.
I was like in tears from just hilarious, hilarious.
But I remember first before you go on, sorry.
I remember when you returned
from that trip to Eastern Europe,
and I know that was a very difficult trip
and there was like a lot of issues
and you were freaking out because you're financing
this whole thing and it's teetering on disaster.
But all I remember about that was your just glee and
enthusiasm at showing, you were like,
you have to see this footage, and you were like, Well,
sit down and let me show you what's going on.
So I had no doubt that this would ultimately become
something because you were so invested in it,
Like you had so much passion poured into like,
making this crazy.
But every time.
As much as every time
this guy would start the fucking camera was
going on, man, You just go.
What the fuck?
Okay, let me give you an example
of what happened on first day of shooting in Prague.
We shot and it was just madness.
And the promoter tried to pay the band in Gola
and there was a big,
there was a physical fight between Lips rather.
It was like, it was just, it was just madness.
Who's the guy that's supposed to pay me?
To pay you?
I think it's supposed be (indistinct).
Yeah, Where is he?
It's guy, the (indistinct)
What's going on here?
(indistinct chatter)
That's nice.
I guess he figures if he gives me a bit of Gola,
I'll forget about it.
He's not paying us?
No, we're not getting paid.
Where's the fucking club owner?
You are too late.
If I was too late, I wouldn't have fucking played pal.
You gonna fucking pay me.
You mostly, most people goes away.
Most of people goes away.
No, I did my full set.
I did my work. I want to get paid.
Sorry. Nobody call me.
I am on road. You should have told-
I never, before we fucking played
and wouldn't have fucking played.
You fucking piece of shit. You fucking pay me.
(indistinct chatter)
I'm crazy.
Yeah I am fucking crazy.
I just worked my ass and you won't fucking pay me.
You're a motherfucker.
So my, my cameraman, who is absolutely brilliant,
Chris Seus at the end of the shoot said, "Okay, look,
I need to talk to you. Right?"
So I, and he was very serious, and I thought, fuck man.
He, I just thought he'd got some news,
like a family member was dying or something,
I thought he was gonna have to leave.
So he says, let's go back to the hotel.
We go in the elevator.
I was like, Do you wanna talk?
He said, "Just hold on".
We go into his hotel room, he turns around,
I'm standing in the li in the little living area of his
hotel suite in Prague.
He locks the door and he turns around around to me
and he says, I need to know, are they actors?
My own crew did not believe what was happening.
They thought that I had hired, It was a whole, whole,
the whole thing was a whole prank.
I was doing like a Michelle Gore style matter joke
on the crew.
And I was like, Dude, no, this is Anvil.
And he said, "I don't believe you".
I said, "Go online man, look it up".
And he looked up 25 years of history and he was like,
Have you, Like, he could not believe that it was real.
And that's when I knew we had something
because it was impossible.
Still to this day,
people think it's a mocumentary.
Some people think that they don't believe it's a real film.
And they, like in Gowan Island, when we,
when we-
I been refused
to be an actor.
So these Irish girls came up to Robb Reiner
and they were like, Dude, you're not Robb Reiner,
that's the director's final tap-
You wanna see my, you wanna see my passport?
She goes, no-
Shows these passport.
You Hollywood tapes can get anything printed.
And any, he, they did not believe him
showing his passport.
These girls thought it was a prop.
I'm like, No, it's real.
People still don't, but it's real.
So I knew that was something.
And then the second thing that happens when we finally got
the film together and we did get into Sundance,
we screened it and it was incredible.
Like, all these people showed up to support us.
And I was like, you know,
I had literally mortgaged my house for this film.
And I was like, if this doesn't work, it's like a disaster.
But I was like so pleased I'd done it anyway.
And I was thinking to myself as the movie was beginning,
like, if it all goes horribly wrong,
like I still am proud of this film, I just don't care.
And then people started laughing and then the audience
started to get involved, and then they got emotional.
And at the end of the film,
there was such an incredible response-
Standing ovations.
It was a genuine response.
You know what film festivals, sometimes the air is,
you know, everyone's a little bit high,
but you could tell it was really extraordinary.
And "Anvil" then went out afterwards to the,
it was snowing in Sundance and they had this van
and they were selling T-shirts and copies of the album.
This is 13.
And there was a line like almost everyone from the theater,
which was like 700 people was trying to buy stuff.
It was madness.
And I remember there was this 78 year old woman who was in
line and who came back with three,
This is 13 CDs and a T-shirt.
And I was like, What does, like,
it was like Angela Landsbury, well, like,
what is she doing?
And I stopped her.
I said, "Madam, I hope you don't mind,
I'm just asking like, who are you?"
And she was a history teacher at a high school in Park City,
retired, you know, she was basically a high school teacher.
And she, I said, "Well,
why did you buy three of these records?"
And she hold them up and she said,
"I will never listen to these, but I just want to help".
And I knew then that this film had the potential
to reach people way beyond metal, beyond music.
And it was about the human spirit.
And it contained.
And again, when you're making a film,
you have no idea what you're doing.
You just hope that something happens.
And in this case, I just hoped,
and what we discovered from the film was that
it was about not giving up.
You know, it was about friendship.
It was about family. It was about not giving up on a dream.
And like what could be more universal than that?
And I think that's why here we are 13 years later,
releasing the film again, it's because of those themes.
And it's also.
And it becomes timeless.
Yeah, it's this meta story
because the film is crazy successful
and that breathes life into your career.
And then you get this, you know,
new third act or second act depending on how you look at it.
Where suddenly.
Well, no, my, my,
my ship really came in and it couldn't have come
in at a better time.
And I mean, life,
life has got a lot of different things
that you realize when everybody else
is closing down their shop.
I just opened up.
Which is a great thing because-
You're preparing for this life.
Everybody's closing down their shop
because they're burnt out
and they have no heart left to do it.
And they're quitting.
And it's like, I find that how do you,
if you're real artist, you should be here till, till you,
till you're pushing up Daisy's. And that's the end of it.
And we had so many moments, like ironically,
you know, someone said that, you know, in one, in one sense,
this film is a portrait of failure.
But the irony being that it led to the band's incredible
success to this day and I remember so many moments,
but one of them was ACDC
asked "Anvil" to open for them at Giant Stadium.
I remember standing on the side of the stage and me
and Lips were like, I was just, I got so, you know,
it was really emotional man,
because you had 50,000 people screaming for "Anvil".
And this was this little movie that we all kind of made in
my kitchen and edited on my dining room table.
And it was just like overwhelming.
And that has continued even in the years that the films,
in the last 13 years and just so many unexpected crazy.
So the movie opens with all these luminaries
and legends like Slash and Scott Ian and Lars Ulrich,
talking about how influential "Anvil"
was and how much they love the band.
And it sort of smash cuts to, you know,
you delivering food to schools and you get this portrait of,
you know, current day "Anvil" and what your lives are like.
So while these other bands who were influenced and,
and kind of behind you leapfrog,
you become crazy successful.
You guys are still back in Toronto kind of doing your thing.
How did you not become like bitter or resentful?
Or were there moments of that like,
I just see you guys as as just very grounded and Lips
I mean, you're this person who has this huge capacity-
It depends on how you wanna look at...
You know, if you, it's a real big thing.
If you measure everything, Oh,
I gotta be a millionaire to be considered successful,
you're an idiot.
It's like owning a hardware store.
I want to be Home Depot.
You don't have to be Home Depot.
You can be the small hardware store
on Main Street and do just fine and make a living
and be known to everybody in the town.
Just the same way as Home Depot.
You know, you're not making the millions at Home Depot is,
you don't have a place that that at can hold it.
It doesn't,
but it doesn't matter because you're doing what you,
you have passion, you love being that small shop.
And that's exactly what "Anvil" is.
It's not a story about,
about a band that wasn't successful.
You don't call a band who's done 12 albums at that point.
Unsuccessful. They've got 12 albums out.
Being unsuccessful would be something.
They did an album and they don't exist anymore
for 20, 30 years.
No, we did an album every couple years.
Generally speaking for our entire-
You've got 18 albums out?
Yeah. So it's like 19.
That's not, that's not unsuccessful.
And also the rerelease of the film is coordinated the 19.
More success.
So, but instead of getting, having a one hit album in the,
in 1980 and then,
and then being retired in 1982 and being here at 65 with
nothing to do, and all my money's gone.
I've gotta, I'm having the time of my life at a time when,
when, when I can't do physical labor,
everything worked out perfectly
as far as I'm concerned for my life.
When I had the physicality and the,
the abilities to go do physical labor, it kept me in top,
top physical condition.
Here I am at 65, I'm not 300 pounds.
I still weigh 150 pounds, whatever.
And the thing about that tour that you see in the film
is like, this is the attitude.
Like they would go out and play
to someone in a rocking chair.
They played the same show
they played at Giant Stadium to 50,000 people.
They live it, they do it.
And I just found having-
Like, well, that's what it is doing.
Why are you doing this?
You have to ask yourself why you're doing,
You're doing it because it's fulfilling your soul.
That's what you're driven to do.
That's what what I do.
I am not driven. I got a top single hit.
I'm not interested. Never was.
I wanted to be the band that that existed on a,
an underground level for 40 years.
And then on their 50th year
when they're just about finished,
they put out a top, top 10 hit album.
And it sells like crazy.
Now you retire, at 75 years old.
I'll give you example as you mentioned,
all the luminaries, like Lars Ulrich, you know,
who of course knew the band who I think we met back way,
way, way back in the day.
You know, Lars called me after he said, you know,
we Metallica watched "Anvil" on our jet
drinking champagne in tears because that could have been us.
And there was just something so like you were talking about
sliding doors earlier.
You know, well-
Steve Harrison said that exactly,
in a blink, I could be you, you could be me.
Because it, to a great degree,
Rock and roll is really to a great degree,
99% chance in being at like, let me said, there's lot-
(indistinct chatter)
Signing the wrong contract,
there's having the wrong manager, the wrong time,
all that kind of stuff.
Dave Rules said that to us.
You make your own luck, but you gotta connect with it.
In certain respects,
you can make the argument that you guys are way ahead of
your time because it was always just about connecting with
your audience directly, right?
And just putting out these albums
for the people that love you.
And now we're finally in this economy where artists,
musicians can do that.
They can sidestep these gatekeepers
and these record companies.
I mean, for a long time during the formative years
when all these bands were getting huge,
it was the record company making a decision.
This is the band we're gonna invest in.
They're in cahoots with the radio stations.
This is what gets played.
And this is the producer.
We're gonna power the songs.
We're gonna have musicians play their parts
because they can't play them well enough.
We're gonna get makeup artists
so that they don't look so ugly.
Everything that they do that they do and did,
and probably still continue to do.
And groom, groom pop, pop, popular, popular.
And if we're being true,
you have your loyal fan base,
you've always served them and
you have direct connection
and you're fulfilled in doing that.
That's right, but it's actually over the last,
since the movie, it's been expanding.
That's actually part of a great reality.
It's, it's not,
it's, we always have new people.
And by the way, when we're making the movie,
we had no idea what was gonna happen at all.
Like, I remember Robert during the filming,
there was some crazy stuff he told me aside and he said,
"You better edit this right
'cause this could be really bad".
And I was like, "Dude, you gotta trust me man.
I love you guys. I'm your fan.
I want all of this to work for the band".
And I was very,
and I said to them when I showed them the film
for the first time, I said,
"If there's anything you really hate or anything that you
don't feel is authentic or true, I will take it out.
I'm not in the business of trying to upset my friends.
I want all of this struggle to be shown so that people will
understand what you guys have been through
to be able to do this".
I don't know what you want, what you want.
You sit here, all Dave pouting, it's crap.
You're causing disruption.
Let it all out.
You fucking listen to me, you fucking asshole.
what you smile? You're smiling at a fucking loser.
You're a fucking loser.
That's what you are.
Put it all down guys.
Come on guys, come and sit down,
It's destructive, it's negative energy.
What are you doing?
You got everything fucking going for you.
And everybody tells me that, you right,
Everybody's tells me that constantly. You right.
I agree. So maybe-
So where are you going? What are you doing?
I'm gonna go pursue something
a little bit more satisfactory
than I guess what's happening with you, sorry.
You pushed me away. I'm accepting your offer.
I'm onto the next page.
(door slamming)
Why is this happening?
I'm fucking sick of it. I can't fucking deal with it.
You know, it, we're gonna come apart at the seams.
I don't know what, what's gonna happen.
I'm fucking, I am so fucking fed up.
Like we gotta get a drummer.
I mean, I don't know what to say.
I'm, he's fired.
I mean, what can I say?
And I think your strength as a,
as a writer and a filmmaker Sacha ,
is understanding that emotional piece
and knowing how to tap into the heart center
of what the story is really about. So-
Come on, remember the guy,
the guy films this in the middle of
a heated brutal argument.
And he's like, he's got a big smile on his face.
I go, What the fuck?
'cause I waited two years from this moment.
He's gonna make sure that the audience is in love with.
He's gold from heaven.
You know what I mean?
Cause here's the thing, like, and you said it earlier,
like it's not about, like when Rebecca said like,
I don't like metal, but I need to tell this story.
It's like, you don't have to care about metal at all.
And I, you know, I think getting people past that,
like getting them to understand that,
which perhaps is a barrier
to getting people to see the movie.
Like it's not really about that.
It's about this lifelong friendship
and what these guys, you know,
have endured over these many years and this passion that
they've shared to pursue this thing that they love
no matter what.
But you know what's interesting is,
is as you say, it's right,
it started off as a kind of metal rock thing,
but in terms of music, it's now expanded to country to rap.
Like I know that there are rappers who have "Anvil" on their
tour bus as opposed to you know, other films.
It's just gone through whole of music and then
it's gone a little bit through sport and then
it's gone a little bit corporate.
Like I know that the movie was shown at a corporate retreat
for a massive Fortune 500 company.
You know, just in terms of like-
It's just, it showed in schools.
It's I know.
(indistinct chatter)
Yeah, we've done Q and As at universities.
We did one in Ireland.
Yeah. A big university.
It's just be, and you could never have imagined.
And what what's beautiful about it is that
it continues to keep going, right?
Like out of the blue, and I know unexpectedly, you know,
and Lips and Robb have received, you know,
hundreds of emails over the years from people who are really
suffering and you know, in some cases terminally.
This is to like what I want to know about like,
'cause there is a whole like inspirational kind of,
you know, self-help piece to this in that people are finding
inspiration through your story and are seeking you out for,
you know, a little piece of that.
Yeah, yeah.
It's been going, it's been going on.
They thank you, they thank us a lot.
For some reason it gives people hope
when they watch that like,
'cause we're so hopeless or can be more hope.
I don't know.
I mean, Jimmy Page said, "You give us all hope".
Well its okay.
It's honest because this is the truth.
This is the truth.
And I think that was the thing because of our relationship
that goes back for 40 years, you know, actually, you know,
when the film comes out,
it'll be 40 years that since we first met, you know,
there's something pure and they,
these guys had to trust me and I had to tell them, Listen,
I am gonna have to show stuff that's gonna be funny.
First of all, you guys are funny.
And second of all,
I'm gonna take the audience on a journey
and if I encourage the audience to kind of laugh
at the Anvil stuff,
which is funny, trust me, it will turn.
And by the end,
the people that they thought were funny in 15 minutes in are
gonna be hopefully if it works,
really moved by and connect with in an unexpected way.
And that's everything as you point to a theme of my work is
like, people who are on the outskirts or you know,
different, whether it's Hervey Villa or you know,
Alfred Hitchcock or Tom Hank stuck in an airport, you know,
these are all people that are not mainstream society and
bringing you into their emotional world
and making you realize that we are all basically the same.
You know, and it doesn't matter whether you wear
a bullet belt and a, you know,
and a beanie and what kind of music you're playing,
you know, we're all human beings.
And that's what I think was the intention of the film.
And I think what's really good is that it's reached,
it's reached people in a human way.
So it started off in a music thing
and now it's just gone to people.
And you know, the,
some of the most remarkable stuff for me is,
is talking to cancer patients and people who,
who have lost, are about to lose everything.
And it actually gives me an appreciation for how,
how lucky I am in so many ways.
It's actually, I don't realize what I've done
for somebody else,
but I know what they're doing for me.
It's making me feel,
it was just remarkable to the point where
I've been actually involved in doing Zoom sessions
with people who are terminally ill and with other,
other musicians that are famous and fulfilling their,
their dream of meeting somebody that's famous.
Oh, that's cool.
And although it,
it seems very frivolous and nothing to me
to just sit here and go, Hey, it's nice to meet you, man.
I'm really sorry to hear about your sickness,
but you know what?
Every minute counts.
So let's have a good time right now and you can,
let's just talk about all kinds of things.
You don't necessarily talk about,
about Anvil's music or anything like that.
You end up talking about just life in general,
about how much they love their children and how, you know,
all different aspects of other people's lives on it.
You're going, Wow, look at that.
And I'm thinking, look it,
you'd never think then in a million years that somebody who,
who plays a guitar with a vibrator means that much to
somebody who's dying.
It's like, what?
That's what's really important
and that's what matters in life.
So I think there's, you know, to your point of,
of taking audiences on a journey and you know,
having them really connect.
I think we're all in search of,
of finding something that's real and there's an earnestness
with the way that you guys live your lives and conduct
yourselves and unbridled like authenticity.
Can I also say a kindness because here's.
(indistinct)
Not been sweet to me.
It all comes around because of that experience.
What I noticed,
the first thing as I said I noticed about "Anvil" was they
spoke to me, their fan,
in exactly the same way that they spoke to Steve Harris of
Iron Maiden or what, whoever it was.
There was no difference for them.
They were kind,
I'm not the first fan by the way that "Anvil"
has invited on the road.
A lot of their roadies are fans who get
to get up close and personal with.
So their attitude,
their whole attitude towards people and fans, you know,
had they been, you know,
I'd got into that changing room at the Marquee Club in
September, 1982, and they were like,
I'm busy talking to the guy from Iron Maiden.
You know, none of this would've happened.
It doesn't happen.
It was who they were.
And there's something very instructive about that.
In terms of like how you live your life
and how you treat other people.
Hell we don't know.
To us it was more remarkable.
More remarkable that, that when,
when he walked into the change,
it was much more remarkable in the sense that he knew the
music so inside out and he wasn't from the same country.
And this was our first time overseas.
This is the first time we've actually met a fan who has been
introduced and knows us by our music from a far away.
He didn't come see us at the Gasworks,
he didn't come see us at the Young Station.
He knows nothing of what we've done to get where we are,
but he knows our music thoroughly.
And it was an amazement look at how powerful music is that
we've inspired this kid who lives here in England.
This was what.
This is what we hoped.
It was because of their music.
That there's a movie.
It's because of their music I connected in with how
extraordinary they were and are.
And it's astonishing that here we are,
like 40 years later discussing this.
I can, and I can't believe that, you know,
we're very fortunate that I'll...
So the rerelease,
I'll just explain a little bit of how this happened.
Yeah, well let's preface that by saying
the movie goes on to touch millions of people
all over the world.
It's since been placed on all of these, you know,
best rock documentaries of all time lists from Newsweek to
The Guardian to, you know, NME.
Like all of these places have placed "Anvil story of Anvil"
among the top 3, 5, 10 rock documentaries of all time.
I mean, and we look at these lists
'cause we got the Newsweek list recently and you're like,
you're on a list with like,
you know, "Woodstock" and "Gimme Shelter" and you know,
and the "Bob No Way Home",
the "Bob Dylan" movie and all these incredible films
and "Amy", which I love, you know, and all, and we are in,
and it's like hard to believe.
Like, like what.
This is our little movie.
We've encountered all of us over the years,
so many fans and other filmmakers who just,
you can't believe that they've even seen the film.
You're so sort of touched.
Well, the, the thing is,
the thing is about it is the access.
And it really is about the access of,
of the director to the subjects of the documentary.
He had a 100% access.
You don't usually get that.
And trust.
And trust
You just, you're not gonna get it.
Who's, who the hell is going to, you know,
have their basically hand around each other's throat
and let your, let yourself get filmed?
During the hope that whole thing,
when I was saying that, that he's saying,
I waited two, three years for this.
We didn't have it.
It's very, very uncommon for us to get like that.
We got like that through the,
the pressures and stress of being in the studio and
everything that was going on,
the moment-
Working with a crazy producer.
Everything was culminated it and created it.
And it was also the band was really on the edge.
Like it was either make or like
this was gonna happen or not.
The whole band was the,
and obviously when there's a movie.
Everything he's on the edge of
am I gonna make it with this?
I'm on the edge with I'm,
I've spent everything we've got in the bank,
I've lent money from my sister.
Just an endless list of oh my God, if this goes sour.
And it continued because when we had this incredible
reaction at Sundance, it was in 2008 and the,
the documentary market was the absolute, it was a disaster.
It was the financial crisis.
And, you know, I was like facing love, people love.
I remember one major distributor came to see the movie came
out in tears, he said, "I absolutely love your movie.
I just can't sell it".
It's just too, you know,
it's just too weird to sell major.
Anyway, so I remember being on the phone with my agent and,
and manager and they were like, Look,
you've been offered this DVD deal with this company.
Very good company.
You'll get some of the money back
and you should just take the deal.
Everyone's loves this movie, you know.
And I just thought about it overnight
and I was like, fuck it.
No, I'm fucking releasing this movie into theaters.
And I called up Lips and Robb and I said,
"We're not fucking giving it away to some DVD company.
It'll disappear. This movie's too important".
Because every place that we'd shown it had,
I just trust the audience.
And so I took a mortgage to take the,
to take the movie out and take it into theaters.
And we got an amazing guy called Richard Horvitz
in New York.
And we got an amazing guy called Scott Feinstein and
Cynthia Schwartz.
And I paid for all that because I knew this movie
needed to get out there.
And it was like, I was, I was already done,
but I was like, I'm done.
Fuck it, I'm going.
I remember that.
I mean, that was such a ballsy thing to do at that time.
I had no choice.
It's like your done, you're done.
It was pre Netflix
and all the hysteria around documentaries.
And I remember like you trying to figure out
what you were gonna do.
And like double down.
I mean, how much of that is a hat tip
to kind of the inspirational influence of you guys, right?
Like you're like that would've been
an obvious choice for you.
But Absolutely.
Of course's, always investing yourself..
It's never, it's never,
it's never a question of whether it's obvious.
It's like there's no other option.
Like it's not you doing something and it's like,
I've gotta go through with it.
(indistinct chatter)
I would say the whole of my life.
I don't have to do an album and go,
Okay, well I'm gonna bail because I don't think
the song is working out.
No, I'm gonna finish it and I gotta get this job done, man.
And I had, I was in this exactly the same position.
I think what you pointed out is absolutely right.
I was like, what would Anvil do?
They would fucking double down and they'd go for it.
So I got this money and we hired Richard and Scott
and we took it out and
it was just astonishing what happened.
Like the week that we were released, they were on
CNN Good morning.
We did what, we did.
We had, we had,
we had this whole vision of how this was gonna work
and we got everything that we needed, you know,
everything that,
every step of the way we would discuss it
and then we'd make a decision.
We would do this, do that.
We got this guy Josh, who could book all the theaters,
book the band into the Theaters.
So we did the movie and then the band.
Jut like a road show.
And we did it as experience.
And it happened at the LA-
And that's how we released the movie through America.
So people are going fuck.
They watch the movie and all of a sudden the next thing they
know, they got me standing beside them in but with
playing the March of the Crabs, Are you, what?
Are you kidding me?
And and the way it all came to life was it happened at the
LA Film Festival we got in, we actually ended up,
I think winning the audience award
at LA Thought Amphitheater.
The movie was shown on a giant screen.
You were there?
I was there.
Yeah and it was 1500 people, every band from like,
I can't remember like Weezer to whoever.
It was just everyone was there.
The movie played like gangbusters.
It was the summer and then at the end of the movie people
were freaking out suddenly a spotlight.
And you saw Lips on a Roman column,
60 feet in the air with this flying view.
People went nuts because here's the audience able to make
this a happy ending for the band.
And they've just been through with them
through this madness.
And that was how we took the movie out and we did it in
Japan and it was mental in Japan.
Oh we got chased in Japan.
We did. I mean it was Bon and we did it all over the world.
We did it in London.
And I, you know, there's two people I really wanna mention.
Yeah. Shepherd's Bush.
One of them is
Shepherd's Bush Empire, two shows.
It was like crazy.
Scott Ian from Anthrax came out to support.
You know, the really sweet thing,
and I just have to give a nice compliment to someone is
Keanu Reeves who I knew and I said, "Dude,
we've got the London Film Festival and like,
is there any way that you could come and help?"
And he said, "Well what do you want me to do?"
I said, "Well if you could just come
and maybe intro the film".
I just thought bad about asking
and you know what he shoot,
he flew himself from LA to London
and he introduced the film.
And he did the press line and because people knew
he was coming, 3000 girls showed up.
And we had the Woody Allen premier
was blown out of the water.
We suddenly, and we had,
and there's people like that,
our angels and the other angel who I think
is a long term and super important
Angel was a guy called Rick Crim.
And Rick Crim was the head of talent of VH one at the time,
one of the original MTV executives and VH one had passed on
Anvil, which was, you know, upsetting.
Anyway, cut along story short,
two VH one executives were on holiday with their wives in
Germany and they were somewhere in Munich or whatever and
someone noticed, oh there's a film festival downstairs.
This was like a rinky dink film festival
was like 11 people at it.
And they were drunk and they thought, oh let's go down.
And "Anvil" was showing 'cause our policy was,
we're just gonna send this everywhere we possibly can.
Something we were hoping that something would happen.
So these two vacationing VH, one executives
drunkenly go to some nothing film festival,
come back to New York and say to Rick Crim,
you've gotta see this movie.
He sees the movie and that begins everything going.
And VH one came in and MTV and you know, Van, Well.
The funny,
the funniest thing is of course he had told me
a few months before this,
that VH one and passed and we all of a sudden we get,
Robb gets an email from somebody at VH one,
I'd won a T-shirt and can you please tell me what
I have to do to acquire what VH1 has to do to acquire.
So their website, gets a T-shirt and said,
I want this movie. They call me and say, VH one is calling.
I'm like, "But they passed".
Anyway, what I didn't know was that
the person who passed had been fired
for passing on the movie.
And that began and then,
and then VH one came in and they supported the release
and they supported, you know,
we even did a best Picture campaign.
For Anvil, which we had-
Did you win the Independent Spirit Award?
Yes, we won the Independent Spirit Award.
And then another kind of like Angel still is,
you're still wearing that from wow.
From that night.
Oh my God.
That's the "Anvil" commitment.
I still wear pants from that night.
And Dave Gro gave that amazing speech.
Dave Gro was, I mean he was amazing.
Actually, interestingly,
that we're talking introducing our new album.
Our new album has a song called "Take a Lesson".
And that's the name of the song...
That's a coin from Dave Gro.
And what happened was, we finished,
we finished all the recording and the guy's mixing
and whatnot.
I walk into the, into the fucking control room.
And he goes, Here's listen, here's the,
here's the open and cut for the album.
And I go, what do you mean?
He goes and he starts the thing up and it's Dave
doing the introduction form the Spirit Award
saying this is a lesson in perseverance.
This is a lesson in.
From the heart.
A lesson from the heart, a lesson, it's a pleasure.
I've been in the right place twice in my life.
And this time,
this time I get to introduce a great rock and roll band.
And he introduces Anvil.
And that's how the beginning of our album starts.
And the song's called "Take a Lesson".
I mean, Gro was incredible.
The lyrics actually really talk
with the message he was saying.
It all, it came organically.
We didn't plan it.
Yeah. We didn't plan it.
And it ended up like that. So.
I mean, I mean, I mean,
so the Spirit Awards were incredible.
Dave Gro was incredible.
Well, Anvil do that performance,
he kind of cut away to a very bemused looking Robert Duval
who doesn't really understand what's happening.
He was really.
Like, What about Elton John doing this?
But we had a very.
Christopher Plumber was there too.
That's right. We had a very good,
we had a very good run with the film.
It was out there.
Like I've, there's one quite funny story was we went to the,
the Emmys the Carnegie Hall in, you know, the arts and,
and whatever docs, Emmys, whatever.
And you know,
me and Rebecca were seated like right up on the fifth floor.
So we were like, Okay,
we're definitely not winning anything.
And so anyway, cut along story short,
Rebecca says to me, Just get in,
just go down there in case something happens.
So I go into the elevators to go down
to the floor where they're giving out the awards.
And I got stuck in the lift for about an hour.
And then I came out to discover that "Anvil"
had won the Emmy and I was stuck in an elevator.
And so then I went backstage and I said,
"I made a movie about a band that got,
that got lost and got stuck I got stuck in an elevator".
And so Lester Hut had me come out and they gave me the Ammy,
but it was like typically Anvil,
like an amazing thing happened.
Of course it happened, but of.
Course we weren't there 'cause I was,
I was dealing with a lift engineer at ConAg.
But here's the thing, this movie came out 13 years ago.
Like why are we sitting here talking about it?
I'll tell you, tell you why.
So walk me up to-
I'll walk you through what happened. Right?
Okay so to my godson is a kid called Rio Hanson.
It's Rebecca,
Rebecca Gelder who produced the film. It's his son.
And Rio, you know, I was in England and he said, "You know,
I'd really like to see Anvil". And I said, "I have a print".
I got it out of storage.
And so Rio brought his friends to see the movie.
This is this past summer.
In London?
No, no here.
Oh, here?
In la I was here briefly
and I got the print out and we showed the film
and all of his friends went nuts.
And I was like, they're like 17, 18 years old.
So Rick Crim and I and Rebecca started to do these
screenings and we started to just invite people
to see the film.
And the response from young people was just like,
Why haven't we heard of this film?
So it was just really unbelievable because,
and a lot of it was about,
we've just been through two years of COVID.
It's been an absolute nightmare.
People have really,
you know, people have lost people.
I mean, I have in my family, you know, so it's been a,
it's been a really horrible time.
And suddenly here's a movie with the message of hope about
enduring almost absolutely impossible situations
and somehow not giving up.
And so for whatever reason,
that theme began to land with a totally new audience.
And then we had this fantastic British singer
called Young Blood come and he came and he brought his,
and he's 23 year old and you know, never heard of Anvil.
And you know,
a very big artist now in the UK
and all these people just started coming.
All young people.
And then all the old fans,
some of those people came back and they were like,
this movie is, I'm feeling this now.
It was, I really enjoyed it then I'm really feeling it now.
And out of these screenings we did about eight that Rick and
I principally put together.
Two distributors emerged that friend of a friend.
Oh, I went to see this "Anvil".
Anyway, so we had two separate distributors approach us to
re-release the film for the 13th anniversary 13 years later.
And we decided to go with this incredible company called
Utopia, who's kind of, I guess like the new A 24 Sky,
Robert Schwartzman, who himself was the band Rooney,
and really understood it. And he was like, Look, there is a,
and he was a couple of the screenings and he's like,
the response I'm seeing from the kids is this is a film that
needs to get out there again and we wanna rerelease it.
And so that's how it all happened.
But it began with my-
It's unbelievable.
I mean, that never happens.
It never happens.
13 Years later. Why do you think now?
Like what do you think it is?
Because 13 is a lucky number.
I know, well like, this is 13.
(indistinct chatter)
But what do you think is happening?
Like what is it,
what's going on in the culture right now that you think
is lending itself to this interest and enthusiasm?
I really don't know.
I think that people are so bored of plastic,
fake kind of Instagram kind of phoniness
that I think there's a sense of, you know,
this is something completely authentic and real
with real history and there's a purity to what "Anvil" do.
And there's also a purity and honesty to the film.
And I think whenever it's purity and honesty,
people gravitate towards that no matter what time you're in.
I think that for me, what happened was the COVID thing,
you know, it just made people really like, this is fragile.
Life is super fragile and you know,
don't take it for granted that everything's gonna be great
and you can go to the store and buy what you want.
And you know, it's, you know what, No, actually,
and I think that people got really appropriately scared,
the world shut down and people started thinking
about what was important.
And I think this film speaks to what really is important,
which is how you treat other people.
Are you doing something you love?
Are you doing the thing you love for the right reason?
Are you driven by money and external things and you know,
or are you just committed to being an alive
and present and passionate,
creative human being, you know,
and this movie is kind of, is about those things.
And I think that's the reason.
But it really all started with my godson making a request.
He said, "I'd like to see the movie that you and mommy,
his mom Rebecca, made because I saw it
when I was a kid or whatever.
And I really wanna see it".
And so Rio was the reason, and again, and a personal reason,
it's my godson saying,
I wanna see this film that you and mum made.
And that's always been the way with Anvil.
You know, it's a really emotional because it's truthful.
And I think we're all so, I like,
I mean the fact that this movie's
being rerelease 13 years later.
I mean, it's bananas.
It's bananas.
I mean, what movies get...
what documentaries get re-released.
And it was like.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It was-
Yeah, it is crazy.
I'm not really sure what, trying to get-
I mean, it's all surreal, right?
Like what is,
what has been the most surreal aspect of this whole
adventure for you guys?
Hmm.
Surreal.
Yeah, just like, sort of like, wow, this guy comes in,
he makes this movie.
I mean, in certain ways your lives have changed
in certain ways.
You guys are doing it the way you always have done it.
But suddenly-
Musically, we-
These interesting people.
We stick to our guns,
you know, like, we know.
So we're not gonna change. I'm really hoping.
I think there's, I'm just-
Stick to our guns with the music, you know?
I want critics to find something new to say about us.
I'm tired of them saying, Oh well this is nothing new here.
Well of course not, find something else to say.
(all laughing)
But the point is that to these guys,
we were talking about this before we came
to do your podcast, that it's their life.
It's normal.
Like, but I said but you understand that the message,
like most people, like how many teenage kids, 13,
14 make a pack to rock together forever
and 50 years later are still doing it?
How many? No one.
And but to them-
well, that's too normal.
Yeah.
That's actually too bad.
Because some of the stuff when you were young
because of your innocence,
you don't see all the obstacles.
Yeah. But you know, I'm not gonna quit on myself.
What for?
Like, I can't, I can't cope with that notion.
Why didn't you quit?
Hey, you quit what you hate.
Not what you love.
You know, I'm a painter, I'm a painter, I paint, you know,
and I paint for myself, you know, people,
I'm come criticize, Oh, you should sell your shit.
It's awesome. You know, people wanna buy it, you know,
you're selfish fucking asshole, you know?
No, fuck you.
You know, it's for me,
it's my passion, It's my hobby.
I enjoy it. It's relaxing.
It keeps me fucking at peace.
You hear me? That's why I do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sure I can make money and this and that, you know,
but you know, that's not what I wanna do.
There's this, people criticize you for that
if you're not selling it or you're not selling
this many of whatever it is that, you know,
you get labeled a success or a lack of success when in truth
you guys are this example of like the purity
of the whole thing.
Well actually there is and honesty-
The real truth. The real truth about what art is.
It's not the guy who's makes the most money from his art or
sells the most paintings, or the guy who sells more,
most records or the guy who has
the biggest selling hit single.
It's about the guy who wrote the most songs.
The guy who is able to express themselves perfect hundreds
of times over that is pure.
Prolific output.
Success.
Yeah, well it's also about the honesty
that you bring to that.
Well, it's the same thing.
What's the best painter,
the guy who could fill that canvas thousands of times.
Like for example,
I mean one example because when we made the film,
I was living on right opposite the artist David Huckne.
And you know that guy because he was my neighbor.
I got to know him a little bit.
He was never stopping painting.
I mean he was constantly,
even when he had people over for tea,
he would be on the iPad like doing stuff like constantly.
And there is something to what Lips is saying about just
doing the thing for its own sake and not thinking about what
it means or what success, you know.
And obviously the-
Guy who does the most
is the winner, that's the guy,
the guy who's expressed himself the most.
That's the winning quality.
It's the, and the ability and the,
the imagination to do that it makes you the winner.
Not what you get after doing it.
It's doing it to begin with.
That is the thing that's the most important.
A shining sort of success story
in the vein of the War of Art, right?
Like it is, I mean you guys,
you have resistance in your life,
but you're always creating, like,
I don't get the sense that you have writer's block, right?
No, I don't even know what that means.
I will I say on that subject.
I can tell you that, not even know.
I feel really fortunate 'cause the new "Anvil" album
for the first time "Anvil" has written a song about me
on their 19th record.
And it's gotten all lyrics. It's our time musical.
And I'm so honest.
Yeah, but it's, it's, but it's,
that's fucking gonna be a big song.
I'm excited, it's called, there's two different,
there's my original "Anvil" named Teabag
and then there's my later "Anvil" named Gomez.
What is that about?
This either they came up with.
Well, Teabag is because he's English.
Okay. It has no sexual in connotation.
It's exactly, its tea time.
It's tea time. It's tea time.
(indistinct chatter)
And then, and then Gomez.
And Gomez is strictly just his lifestyle.
You know, somebody, Well.
And the Gomez, Gomez came from when,
when the "Anvil" movie started getting released
and it started becoming successful, he goes,
I've got the best train set in all of Hollywood.
And we went, He's Gomez Adams.
That's right.
He became Gomez.
That was it.
Importantly Robb, does it have a,
a drum part that Sacha can actually play?
No, I can't play anything Robb still to this day.
Well, you know, I, I don't know.
He, he always tries, you know,
we've seen him do what school love.
I've seen him play school love, you know,
he keeps the beat, but when he becomes down to roles in,
he can't keep up to ramble.
There are videos on YouTube though
of Sacha sitting in playing.
It was great.
Well, the best one was in Japan.
When we filmed the end of the movie,
I was invited out to do school love.
And it was, that was pretty wild.
It was like 20,000 people.
So that was intense.
But we, no, but it's just the connection,
the love of the fan for the band.
We like family and we, you know, we're friends.
It is like family actually.
It is.
That's the best way I could describe the friendship
that we have with Sacha .
It's not like, somehow sometimes it connect with,
with certain people in your life in a way that you can't,
you can't really explain it,
but somehow you feel like you've had a past life
or something together.
I don't know. It's.
The movie came from that, you know.
And that's what gives the access.
Not bond is.
You're not gonna, I'm,
we're not gonna have a fight or,
or talk about things or be natural like that.
We just figured let him film everything
and if we don't like it,
we'll just tell him to make it go away
and so we don't have to worry about it.
And that gave a 100% access.
Sacha said to me very early in the whole thing,
looked at me right in the eye and said, "Listen man,
I'm not gonna do, like, like you said earlier,
I'm gonna be straight up, I'm gonna film all this stuff,
but I'm not gonna make anything bad".
Trust me. You know, And I told 'em, I trust him.
You know, we had like, we shook hands and I,
and I felt very comfortable after that point.
I mean, you have to realize
you letting people have access like that.
I went with the French-
And what was,
what was the experience the first time
you watched the movie?
Oh, I had to, I was the last guy to watch See it,
I guess Sacha had it, wanted it that way.
So I was the last person to see side at his house
in that living room.
And as soon it was ended, we ended the film.
Robb looked at me and said, "Play it again".
Like he didn't even gimme a thought
and he watched it twice in a row to absorb.
Yeah, it was, it was, it dazzled me beyond words
at that time.
'Cause, it's not what I expected.
I didn't know what to expect.
He filmed everything,
you know, after a while I said, "Wait a minute".
What kind of movie did you make?
We're making a documentary about a band,
but this guy's like filming things that like family and
fighting and like, like all this other stuff.
Right. So I couldn't get what, like, what, what's what.
So when I saw it, I got it and then I said,
"Oh my fucking God,
this movie's gonna rip people's souls out".
That's what I thought at first.
This movie's gotta kill fucking people, man.
Because it was killing me, you know, watching.
You know, and after the third time,
I just said to them, I think it was a genius piece of work.
And that was before anybody saw it.
So that was my impression.
And again, you, you know, with these things,
if someone sets out to make a genius piece of work,
I mean, you set out, you follow an instinct,
you go with a story, you go with a feeling,
and then you sometimes you have that feeling
and the movie doesn't come out good.
In this case, there was just such purity
and emotion from these guys and
we were so emotional making the film.
I mean, now I look at the film
and I think about all the people who aren't here anymore.
(indistinct chatter)
Like to Robin Lips,
both their mothers are alive in this film.
And Jet Row and Chris Hagar's, the producer.
I mean so many people are-
And the dog.
My dog.
Yeah your brother.
In the English, the English journalist.
The guy who, Yeah.
Malcolm Dome.
He just passed away.
So a lot of people-
And Lemy.
Yeah. Lemy of course.
And you know, after-
Lemy, Lips invite you to join Motorhead at some point,
like early in your career.
Yeah, he did.
You said now?
Well we were both early in our careers,
he was losing Eddie Clark and he was, he's in a panic,
Come and help me.
I know you love Motorhead and you could probably do it.
And I said, "Yeah, I could probably do it, but I can't".
I mean, I'm "Anvil" because-
(indistinct chatter)
I'm going into the studio in a week.
What do you mean join Motorhead?
What what's "Anvil" gonna do?
We're under contract.
And I remember that tour
because Lemy loved the band so much.
He asked "Anvil" to open for Motorhead
on the another Perfect Day tour in 83.
And I went on tour with these guys
as they were opening for Motorhead.
Motorhead have never been louder.
I mean, it was like standing next to
3 777 thinking of it was like, it was almost too much.
But anyway, you were on tour with, with him.
And I remember the moment when Lemy is like, Clark has left,
Brian Robertson isn't working out.
You need to come into Motorhead.
And you know, Lips would not leave Robb
and Rob's had other opportunities himself to go,
you know, to join-
(indistinct chatter)
It's always, this is the way to do it.
Work for yourself, do your own thing, doesn't matter.
You know, dangled carrot's here, man,
can make more money here.
Again, it's not about the money.
I wanna be happy.
I don't feel honest to myself.
So that's why, you know, and this, this feels honest,
you know, this band always has, and so that's why,
that's why we're still here.
Right, Right.
Yeah, I mean, first of all,
like how many bands rock it out for 50 years, stay together?
You guys are best friends still.
I mean, that in and of itself, set aside everything else.
Good friendship.
Unbelievable.
That's right.
Is an unbelievable accomplishment.
So what do you,
I'm sure young musicians,
young creative people want advice from you.
Like, what do you say to that young musician or writer
or filmmaker or anybody who's trying
to burst something creative into the world about like how-
Well, my biggest advice is make something
and be something that no one else can be but you.
That's what it comes down to.
You gotta be you and you gotta find out what that is.
And the way you find out is by doing it and being you.
And then you can slowly recognize what that is and zero in
on it and hone it and get it better and better.
That's how you do it.
Finding your voice, you know,
takes a bit of time sometimes.
Yeah.
(indistinct chatter)
Discover what keys do I sing in best?
What words sound best?
Nevermind. What fits this song?
All, all those things.
It's a learning process.
You know, "Anvil" was a movie that only I could have made,
that's similar to my dinner with Hervey was a movie
only I could made, I could have made, you know,
it's like you've gotta do the thing that's so uniquely
yourself and whatever happens,
it doesn't matter because you are doing the thing
that only you can do.
That's Right. You gotta be honest to yourself.
Like, what do you,
as somebody who you've worked with Spielberg and Tom Hanks
and Anthony Hopkins and all of these people.
It's a difference between being in a cover band
and being in an original band.
You're not gonna make it make playing someone else's music.
Right. That's right.
As simple as that.
Despite like this storied career that you've had,
Sacha, you're best known for "Anvil".
Your most personal movie.
My most personal movie. Yeah.
So with that,
how does that inform how you make choices about the projects
you get involved with?
(indistinct chatter)
Would say, I have a, you know,
pretty healthy career doing,
working, you know, doing stuff, and I'm, you know,
I'm doing another movie with Helen Mirror, you know, again,
there's a lot of personal stuff coming up.
But I would say for me, Hervey and,
and "Anvil" are the two films, which, you know, I think are,
for me, the most personal and the best films.
And, but there's also making a living.
You can't make these kind of, you know,
movies like "Anvil" don't happen every time
you make a movie.
That said, all of the experiences I had
in all the other things helped me
make these personal movies.
Like, "Anvil" came from a pure place,
but I had some experience,
you know, having done other stuff and, you know,
been brought in as a rewrite on, you know,
some quite big movies and I've ghost written lots of things,
and I've also, you know, but working with actors, you know,
like learning how to manage and handle volatile and
difficult emotional scenes and situations.
I mean, that was a skill I think I brought to "Anvil"
because there were times where, you know,
you could tell this train could have come off the track,
but because I had some experience from other areas,
I was able to kind of navigate that.
So there is a connection between the works you do the thing,
the work you do professionally and, and,
and these personal films.
But there's more personal films to come.
So "Anvil" is the first film,
and for those of you who seen it,
ends with a photo of me and Lips taken on a tour of Canadian
hockey arenas in 1985.
My dinner with Hervey ends with a photo of me
and Hervey Village in his hotel
room a few days before he committed suicide.
And there's a third film,
I call them the photograph films that I won't tell you,
but the title is Mizu.
And that will be,
and if I'm known for those films, and I will be,
and principally "Anvil", I'm,
I'm so lucky to have that happen, you know?
And you know, you just, as a filmmaker,
you're lucky if it even happens once. So it's-
Well, no, yeah.
That's the same thing with, with music,
the same thing with me.
You can make you make a real hit for yourself once.
And then basically.
Who knows what happens.
It sustains you.
Look at it, Metal on Metal album
sustained me for 50 years now.
But I, but I would,
but I would say speaking to the point of.
It doesn't mean it's my best album by my standards,
but it set me up so that I could do, you know,
20 other albums.
But I will say the ones where I've struggled the most,
like with Hervey,
me and Peter Dinkler tried to get that movie made
for 17 years.
And we were told flat out, this movie will never get made.
And we persisted.
I took the lesson of Anvil,
and me and Peter Diage applied now,
then "Game of Thrones" hit, and then there was a chance,
and then finally it got made and in the way that we really
wanted to, but that was also years of struggle and stuff.
Yeah. And I watched that, I watched that from the onset.
I mean, at that party that we met you at,
that's when I became aware of the whole story story.
I mean, this is the voter ray, and there was the big-
It was your first Script.
Yeah that script was led to be working with Spielberg.
I wrote a short-
(indistinct chatter)
His girlfriend was at that party.
And that's where his,
his whole focus when I first met him was that
he was gonna make this movie about Harvey's last hours.
And it's like, wow.
And that was, and again, I was told,
Don't waste your time with that.
And I wrote it as a short script,
a 34 page script about Hervey Village shares.
Everyone was like,
this is the most expensive short in history.
I had it budgeted. It was like $4 million in 19, like 98.
Like never gonna happen.
That's what got you an agent. And kind of-
But that got me an agent.
Got your name out there in terms of writing.
I met Steve's alien.
He passed it onto Steven Spielberg that
ended up with me working with Spielberg.
So again, the source of all of it was a personal story
that I was passionate about that only I could tell.
And then "Anvil" also reaching all of these other people
that ultimately leads you into this.
Well, I mean,
the only reason I got to direct Anthony Hopkins
and Helen Meran in Hitchcock was because of "Anvil".
Because Tony Hopkins is a massive "Anvil" fan.
He watched the movie three times.
So when I met Tony Hopkins for the first time,
I put him and Lips on the phone.
He was like, Hello.
Hello. Oh my God, Hello Lips going, Oh my God.
He was doing his Hannibal lecture voice Hello lips,
like whatever he was doing.
But it was like,
what I'm saying is, you, you do this stuff,
You have no idea what's gonna happen.
And the most unexpected things,
like I was told from absolutely categorically
by my agents at the time,
I should not self fund a documentary about an unknown heavy
metal band from Canada that was like career death.
I needed to go meet Adam Sandler and I needed to go meet
whoever else and do these big rewrites at wherever it was.
I had an instinct.
I ignored all the people who told me,
you know, on, on the face of it.
Probably not a great idea,
but it doesn't matter because my instinct told me it was the
best thing and ironically, you know,
I later fired those people, you know, fuck 'em.
Like, if you're not gonna support me.
And of course the irony is that that turned out to be,
you know, this incredible thing
that still is going on 13 years later
where it's coming out into theaters again.
I mean, like, so it just means.
It's actually, it's actually interesting.
I perceived all this, what it was on the onset.
I really, I really-
You're on a
different level with this.
(indistinct chatter)
But the thing is, and I even said, and I,
and even in discussions with my younger brother,
when I told him about the thing he was,
his predictions were, he's going,
your friend is looking to make a very,
very special movie about your failed career,
and it's gonna make both of your careers explode
like a rocket.
And that's what's going to happen outta this
because it's got to,
because it's what, it's sort of what the,
what the fuel is for all of it, see?
And he thought it was just,
if at the onset that's what he's going, this is amazing.
I hope it works out for you.
And when I, and I,
I remember I was at my Uncle Marty's house
at 5 Aver Road in Toronto,
and I called up Lips and he came over and I said,
"I have this instinct to battle film".
It was like, let's have an exploratory conversation.
And Lips broke down into tears because he knew.
Because it was what I had called as, you know,
15 years before when I was sitting
in a car with Johnny Z telling him,
I'm gonna have to wait till a fan grows up
and helps me make it the next time round.
This was my for telling.
But not only that, I,
when the movie did start taking off, I,
I remember having a conversation with Sacha I go,
This is a flag pole movie for you, man.
You're, this is like your metal on metal.
Like, whatever metal on metal was for me,
this is gonna be your metal on metal.
And you, at that time,
you did not want to hear that.
You go, Yeah, what do you mean?
I got a whole, a whole mess of,
I gotta make lots of movies, man,
it can all be big or whatever.
And I'm going, Dude, sometimes you get a special moment.
And you don't know.
And you don't realize it at the time.
He knew much more than I did at the time,
how special it was gonna be when I saw it at Sundance.
And when we went to Hot Docks in Toronto and we did the big
theater and people went nuts, I started to get the sense,
but initially I was like.
Are you crazy, man?
What do you mean?
And I said what are you talking?
Like, when he started crying,
when I told him I wanted to make a movie,
I was like, a bit like, why is he crying?
I didn't really understand,
but he knew like almost he had an intuition before I did
about what was gonna happen.
I could never have predicted though.
And I don't think you could have that 13 years later this
movie would be coming out again, no.t possible
No, but I predict that...
I predicted that it would have a huge, long life.
Yeah. Yes, that's true.
And the reason that I felt it would have a long life is
because the band still exists and it was a meaningful,
it was meaningful enough.
See, this is the thing,
and it's not that I'm full of myself,
that's not where this is coming from.
It's a special band,
and every, everything has its claim to fame or whatever.
This is part of what "Anvil" is.
It's part of the art claim to fame,
and it's going to be long lasting.
And because it's a real spinal tap, it's gonna outlive
the fake one, because it's a real living, breathing entity.
Both things are going to live off of each other
and propel it well into the future until they're,
until one of us disappears.
And it's probably gonna be us because we're human beings
and we have a finite end.
But ultimately what it is one feeds the other.
We go and play a gig,
all of a sudden the movie starts appearing
in local theaters.
They get the...
they buy it from Sacha.
And all of a sudden, every time we go and do a tour,
a movie starts playing in different places.
So it brings life out.
I mean, it was an extraordinary, It was,
it's been an extraordinary journey for me.
Probably one of the high points was Marty Scorsese did a
documentary about George Harrison called
"Living in the Material World",
probably six or seven years ago.
And I was invited completely out of the blue
to a private party at the Beverly Hills Hotel,
a dinner to celebrate the movie.
And I was sitting next to Olivia Harrison and I was like,
I don't know George Harrison or any of them.
And so I'm at this dinner and anyway,
Scorsese comes over and he said, "You did "Anvil"?"
And I said, "Yeah".
He said, "That's my favorite music movie of all time.
Doesn't get any better than that, man".
You know, and we had had a print of the film
go to New York,
and we didn't know who it was for.
And it was Scorsese had personally requested the film
and kept it private and he watched the movie,
and I think he even kept the print.
But to get someone, my hero director come to me and say,
You did something really incredible, that still resonates.
I mean, like, who on earth could have predicted that?
I mean, it just still, that was just like,
for me as a filmmaker, like, I hit that note.
It's unbelievable.
And that just, you know, is you never, like,
I had no idea, man.
I mean, I don't think any of us had any idea
that a lot of this would happen.
(indistinct chatter)
Except for me. Which is then that's okay.
Which was was wonderful to watch you guys learn
when I knew was gonna happen
I was skeptical.
Yeah. This guy was gotta be the worst.
And it's like, dude, we're driving in in Europe and
we're getting lost in the middle of the fucking woods
because we, the crazy tour managers tell,
turn off into this thing,
and we turn down and we're lost in the woods.
Let me tell you a quick story on that.
And I go, do we?
Yeah, but I'm going, we're only gonna have to do this once.
We're never gonna have to do this again.
Trust me, Robb, just, let's just get through it.
And you'll see man is all for a reason.
Chris Seus and Matt Dennis, we're in this,
we're in a camper van following "Anvil" through the
forests of literally, of Transylvania.
We're in Romania, in Transylvania with following.
It's like three in the morning, the crazy tour thing.
It's like, okay, we stop here, right?
So we stop and we are like, what is going on?
Anyway, we got some sleep at 5:15.
The sun came up and we realized that we were on the edge of
a cliff with a 400 foot drop to certain death in a gorge.
And me and Chris woke up and we were like,
We're this far away from dying, and we are like,
we're going to die for "Anvil".
It was like constantly.
(indistinct chatter)
It says like, how are we getting through this?
Like, what the fuck, what the hell is that?
I mean.
The thing is like, what I like,
what I take away from the whole thing though is,
is that when you, when you express from the truest,
deepest part of your heart that you're,
you're basically paving the way for magic to happen.
Not in any kind of guaranteed sense, but you're sort of,
you're sort of casting your vote for like,
mystery to enter your life.
And I think there's something really instructive about
approaching your life or the decisions that you make about
where to invest your energy.
And just Sacha hearing you talk about, you know, you had,
you had done this sort of traditional success track in
Hollywood and it left you feeling, you know,
a little bit fallow or empty and,
and then that reconnection process of finding that thing
that gets you excited when you wake up in the morning and
having the audacity to continue to pull that thread when
there were a lot of, you know,
people trying to talk you out of it and a lot of resistance.
It's just, I think it's just really powerful.
I think people will-
The same story can be said for your entire career and
everything that you guys-
Well, I mean, my, it's,
it's hilarious when I stop and think about it.
My mother's constant nagging me as a kid to,
you gotta go to school and you gotta do this
and you gotta do that.
And you're never gonna, and that you're making a,
you're wasting your life and your decision to make no money.
And and my whole life was focused on proving her wrong.
Was it though?
Honestly,
as crazy as that sounds, it,
I'm gonna prove you wrong
if it's the last thing I do on earth.
You don't strike me as somebody
who's being driven by like resentment.
Like, you seem like you're a pretty happy guy.
No, not, it's not, it's not resentment.
I'm gonna have fun doing what you say I shouldn't do.
And you know, like.
It's teenage defiance.
It's, it's, I never grew.
It's like, yeah, I'm growing old, but I never grew up.
And there's something magical about that.
And I might be, I'm not gonna let, I'm not gonna let,
let a grown up world taint my innocence.
I'm gonna still act as though I've still got a chance
when there might not be.
And I'm just gonna keep going with the innocence.
I can do this.
But, you know, but here's the thing.
When I met Lips on that first weekend,
and he came to LA and you met him, Rich at the party,
I started the weekend thinking, Oh God, this is quite sad.
By the end of the weekend I was like, you know what?
They're, they're gonna fucking do it, man.
And like he was so believed it so much
that had he not had that belief,
there would've been no film to make,
the film was about the story in the present,
about the present.
The struggle right now to keep going.
But come on, let's face it, Anvil's a meant to be,
There are things that are meant to be, And I'm sorry,
I've had that feeling since I,
since I was a teenager.
It's meant to be,
I'm not supposed to quit,
that you're not supposed to.
I'm significant.
I mean something in this world and I'm was gonna see,
I'm gonna see, my old point was
I'm gonna see it through.
I don't give a shit.
Just my mother taught me not to give a shit.
She told me I'm never gonna make it.
And you know what?
The makings of my personality of where it was fostered from.
It was there right to the end.
But, but Rich speaking to your point about success,
you know, about the meaning of success,
which I think "Anvil" is redefining, you know,
like working in Hollywood,
it's so geared to what are the box office numbers, you know,
all that kind of stuff.
It's so geared to external things.
And what I've observed is that if you are happy,
it's usually in spite of success rather than because of it,
You know, success comes from a completely different place.
You know, it's about, you know, I'm like,
I'm so proud and happy because of 'Anvil", but you know,
it's like, it didn't take $200 million at the Box Office.
But I will say that the impact and the depth of the feeling
that it's created in so many people is you couldn't,
it's priceless, you can't pay.
The film also changed my idea and orientation
about what does it mean.
Well, I think in terms of "Anvil" and longevity,
I mean, here we are 13 years later with this movie,
you know, it stands the test of time.
It speaks to people, you know, that's,
you can't buy that, man.
And the movie that took $500 million, 10 years ago,
no one remembers, no one cares about that.
It's about the quality of what you're doing
and the reasons why you're doing it.
And that has to be that always the determining factors in
what I think and what you define as success.
Because I thought, I came to Hollywood,
I went to film school,
I'll sell a movie for a million dollars or whatever,
You know, it's like, that's not success.
That's just a thing that happens
that you have to get over and a-
Kind of piece of luck.
Trying a bit of luck.
And it's like, you know, it works for a weekend, you know,
I remember when that happened, and I sold this in 2005.
I sold a pitch for like, an insane amount of money.
It was the biggest selling pitch of the year.
I remember we sold it on a Friday night,
and by Sunday I was like, in a depression.
I was like, Now I have to write this piece of shit.
It was like, you know, it was just like, it,
the "Anvil" experience totally rewired everything
about what I think is important
and how I feel about what's important and what,
to me, what is important.
So how do you articulate what that is?
Like I said, I just think it's about, you know,
ultimately it's about being
the most authentic human being you can be".
And it's about putting something
into the world that in some way,
to someone lifts them up, is nourishing, is meaningful,
You know, sometimes,
and pure entertainment can be a great diversion.
You take people away from their problems, you know,
they're able to have an escape.
But really to have the ability to make people think,
to make people think about the person right next to them.
And sometimes maybe I'm in judgment,
sometimes maybe I'm in fear, and how about listening?
How about, you know, like just a sense of empathy.
I think that the whole movie "Anvil" is about empathy.
It's about looking past your, you know,
top line judgements and your initial, you know,
everyone rushes to judge man, you know?
But when you strip the layers away and you go deeper,
you find things that you would never expect.
And that's what I love is if, and I,
I think that happened with Hervey,
I think that's happened with Anvil,
is just dig a little deeper
and you may find something that you need.
And I had no idea how profoundly I needed to make this film,
this film, forget what happened,
and Martin Scorsese loves it and amazing.
That's amazing. Right.
But it was the actual experience of spending time
with these people and seeing how our work together
changed all of our lives, like that experience
was incredible because we were on this for years.
I mean, this is not something we did in a weekend.
This was,
and we all sacrificed and we all were
at the absolute brink, and we were near,
I was nearly completely broken by this, completely.
My accountant said, You,
I may have to de declare you bankrupt next year, you know,
And, but it was worth it.
And I was still happy to do it.
And you and I have known each other a long time.
All the stuff that my brother Gary said all came true,
is what we actually did.
From an objective perspective, that's exactly what we did.
Because we're also, Rich and I have known each other
for more than, for 20 years at least.
And we have both been at that point in different ways.
And to survive beyond that point,
to just not give up is the example I got from you.
And it's so many people,
the most interesting people that I know are the people
who've not had it easy actually, who've had a really-
(indistinct chatter)
It's colorful, isn't it?
When it's really colorful. It's really fascinating.
I mean, a lot of the bands all try to,
I just watch all these copycats trying to capture some,
some of the essence of that "Anvil" movie.
But they can't because they haven't really got,
they haven't got the history.
They didn't get the,
they haven't acquired the access that
the director never got the access.
They never get emotional-
Another beautiful thing that happened
that I should mention is that, you know,
"Searching for Sugarman", I love the movie.
And Simon Chin, who produced it is a friend of mine
and the day after they won the Academy Award for best music,
for best documentary, you know,
I got a call from Simon and I think in my league
and to say thank you for opening the door,
because "Anvil" was the movie that changed a lot of things.
And in fact,
the Academy changed their rules around music documentaries
and then "Sugarman" won 20 feet from stardom.
And, you know, so we really did play a part
in opening things up, to this documentary music.
It was like, we were one of those films, I think David.
Yeah. But the biggest, the biggest Difference...
Now The Biggest Difference Between-
(indistinct hatter)
Okay, the biggest difference for the "Anvil" documentary
to every, almost every other documentary made about bands,
they show it all in retrospect.
They never show what we did with the "Anvil" movie.
Let's show what's happening in the moment.
And capture it as we're doing it.
Not talking Heads talking back upon a career.
It's not talking about once what was,
but what are we doing tomorrow
and how we're gonna go about doing it, and let's film it.
So the, I'm in, I have to ask this question.
Like, so the,
the kind of tagline that gets thrown around with the movie
is Real Life Spinal Tap, like you said it earlier,
but I've always wondered like how that lands with you guys.
Like how do you feel about the movie being called that?
I don't like it. I never did.
"Spinal Tap" is the fake "Anvil".
And that's, and that's just-
The title of the Spinal.
"Spinal Tap" is the fake "Anvil".
And funnily enough,
when "Anvil" was started doing the rounds
and started people,
you know, "Spinal Tap" was on their 25th anniversary.
And those guys who I love, because I love that movie, right?
This, this was like, like for me, my two favorite films,
"Spinal Tap" and "With Nail and I",
and "Anvil" is a sort of combination of those two films.
And so when they were,
they got so sick of hearing about "Anvil"
on their 25th anniversary, they told their publicist,
I don't want any questions. They didn't want any questions.
(laughing)
And what happened was,
we had an MTV reporter interviewed them
and they stay asked about "Anvil", like against the rules.
And you could tell that Nigel Tufnel was very upset.
And that Broad said, "What's it like?"
You know, when you hear about "Anvil" and Nigel Tufnel
looked at David St. Hubins and Derek Smalls,
and they obviously were like, really not happy.
And Nigel Tufnel turned and he went,
It's like being crushed by a piece of art.
That's what he said. And I seen the clip of that.
That's Great.
Sweet about it. So I'd love to get you know them together.
It would be great.
That has to happen.
I think so.
You must do that around this.
I mean, it would be lovely if they were to it.
I don't know, you know,
what their attitude towards "Anvil" is,
but I think when Robb said, you know, they're the,
they're the fake "Anvil".
I mean, but, you know.
But you cut 'em off, Rob,
you were gonna say something else too.
Yeah, no, just, it's just a,
it's a good hook catch for marketing.
I thought the "Spinal Tap" thing comparing us,
but we're nothing like that.
In my mind, at all.
We're real fucking musicians, man.
Those guys are, are.
It's a fake. It's fictitious.
None of it's, everything is taken from,
everything is taken from real life and re-recreated.
Whereas the "Anvil" film is,
it is real life and there is no recreation.
The reason "Spinal Tap" is so great is
because it's so close to the truth.
But those guys got it from bands like "Anvil" and Jetro Toll
and Saxon and whatever else was their inspiration.
All of the things that happened,
like when Derek Smalls gets caught in the Chrysalis Pod,
he's like, I mean, that happened.
And the cucumber,
the cucumber down the pants, that was stolen up
the Biff did it.
(indistinct chatter)
So all of these things are taken from real things.
That's why they're funny.
So I dunno that there's, you know,
we could be that upset about it.
It's a good marketing catch.
Yeah. It's a,
people love familiar that familiarity and,
and be able to at least be able to tag it to something else
so that at least they know, and to be able to explain it to,
to somebody else.
It's like some, what's that band like?
Well, they're sort of like that.
Well, in the same sense, what's this movie like?
Well, it kind of reminded me of "Spinal Tap".
So it's kind of a catch a catch a hook.
A hook and catch kind of thing kind of thing.
The real original "Anvil" pounders.
They're not happy with any of it.
(indistinct hatter)
They don't need a movie to tell us that.
You know, you guys are a good band
and all that kind of shit.
So, you know, we dealt with that all along from the,
our original base, you know what I mean?
But you know what was really interesting?
They liked the movie, but it was,
they felt like they didn't like it the same
as somebody who's not a fan.
But, you know, But you know,
what was interesting was that all bands,
whether they're heavy metal or pop or rappers or whatever,
they've all, they have similar things happen.
Like, I remember speaking to Chris Martin.
They all do.
Of course. Because that's the what life...
Mistakes happen. That's what happens in everyday life.
That's what happens. Why are there car accidents?
They're not happening on purpose. You know what I mean?
They're accidents.
But come on man.
It's the same,
it's the same thing with anything that goes on on the world
band or whatever, stuff happens.
That's a present for you, Rich.
Let me see.
It's something very special to limited edition.
You may wanna try that, but for these times,
It's an "Anvil" mask.
Can you live without an "Anvil" face mask?
I actually have to go to Canada in a couple weeks
so I can wear this for that.
You have an official "Anvil" mask.
That limited edition.
What happened to the sequel?
I know you guys were working on solving world peace
at some point.
Well.
We, we started shooting.
Really disappointed to hear that
the actual trailer is gone.
No, no, no. We have, we have it somewhere.
Oh, now we have it.
We do have it.
John, John has it.
Not John Peter.
We do have the trailer.
The issue is we started shooting
and I think we all got busy with different things.
And it also got very heavy because
the band was invited to Israel.
We were gonna go to Israel.
A lot of it was around the, you know,
the Jewish family history of Robb and also of Lips.
And what we did manage to do,
which I think may at one point resurface, I don't know,
but Lips and Robb went to Auschwitz where Rob's father had
escaped from, and his grandfather,
unfortunately had passed away.
And they looked in the book at the camp.
The register.
And the Rhino family name was there.
And I have this incredible moment, remember?
On the suitcases.
Oh, the suitcases.
My relatives of my mother's. My mother's family.
Really, really hard to take, actually.
For me, because it's just like, ah, that's okay.
It never really affected me.
I don't, didn't know these people.
They were all dead before I was born.
But that's the whole, that's the whole bloody point.
And when I, when we went there, I was like,
so it was such an awakening.
Because what you came to realize,
this happened not that long ago.
And when you hear about, you know,
when you're a little kid and,
and you hear about all this stuff through your whole life,
you're thinking, they're talking about ancient history.
You never think about it.
You know, when we show up there,
and I'm looking at the electric fences,
and I'm going, this isn't that long ago, man.
And these buildings look like stuff in and around home.
This is not ancient.
This is within the last 50 years, man.
That that building is no older than my house.
Wait a minute.
That means,
and then all of a sudden it started really sinking in that,
in my era and in my lifetime, I am still,
I am still attached to the atrocities that went on in that,
that bloody place.
That there are literally hundreds of lost souls
that I'll never know that I should have known.
And then I started to come to realize of all the,
the people that should or would
or could have been in the world today.
And the kind of differences,
those people just as simple as when I realized,
look at Rob's father's survival of Auschwitz
brought a speed metal.
What else could got, what else could,
could have gotten lost in Auschwitz
if Rob's father didn't survive?
Would people be using double bass drums the way they do
today because Robb doesn't exist?
Would I have had a drummer play, to create this stuff with,
I mean it's a lot of those things started to dawn.
So in the filming,
we all came to this realization that Rob's family
and Lips' family,
because he discovered that one of his relatives who we
didn't know her name was written on one of the suitcases
in the display.
And then it suddenly occurred to us that it's possible
the Lips' relative and Rob's grandfather and father
knew each other at Auschwitz.
And then the cameraman, Chris Seuss, you know,
his family was also had lost people at Auschwitz
and in the Holocaust and my family, Toronto Jews also.
And there's this underpinning of this incredible story of
the Jewish immigrants and what happened
in Germany in the 1930s.
And all of the key people in this movie,
in one way or another,
either come from that or are connected from it.
And then it just,
so that in it itself was maybe the reason why we,
we did all the filming that we did because it brought us to
so many different realizations.
And then we thought, you know-
But I mean these things came afterwards that.
We're not really,
we weren't really conscious of during the making of the
movie that it would have that, that it would,
that we'd be left with these feelings that,
that it would evoke these things.
I was not thinking about the Holocaust
during the whole movie.
It wasn't after that came to really, we wouldn't be,
we ended up at the,
at the Jewish Film Festival in San Francisco.
And I'm standing outside the place.
And I look across the street and I,
I look at this fence and it's got barb wire on top,
and all of a sudden I go,
I wouldn't be standing here if Rob's father
didn't survive Auschwitz, I wouldn't be here.
And neither would all these people lining up to see the
"Anvil" movie.
And I started coming to realize, holy shit,
talk about meant to bes or something.
This is overcoming not only,
not only overcoming my obstacles,
it's my fellow tribesmen.
We've, our survival has,
has brought forth some of the most important things that in,
in human history.
And the coming to realize what got lost.
I don't think people ever stopped to think about what the
possibilities and the potentials that got lost in,
in that period of time and in all wars.
Not just that, but, and the persecution of a certain people.
And the impact that could have for,
for the rest of human history.
I don't,
like a lot of things came to, you came to realize from,
for myself personally, from doing that "Anvil" movie,
otherwise, where would I get that stuff from?
And we discovered lots of really,
really weird things like Lips' brother Gary
bought a house that my grandfather Jack Caso
owned in Toronto.
There were all these crazy connections
and Chris's family too.
And it was all about,
it was all about the kind of-
the survival.
But what happened, so this movie never got-
We shot a lot of stuff and I think we all got busy and we
always said to each other, you know, we may come back to it,
who knows because a lot of that footage over that time and
interviews have been shot.
It could be that in 10 years time,
all this we've shot over six years-
(indistinct chatter)
There is an appetite for it.
There, if it got made and blah, blah blah,
everybody would wanna see.
We get asked all the time, all the time.
The idea was that we'll make a,
we'll make a film about Judaism and identity and survival.
That becomes a really interesting "Anvil" sequel,
"Anvil two Quest for World Peace" was the original title.
But then I thought, let's call it Metal in the Shuttle.
But so, you know, it's like, it's ongoing.
I don't know what's going-
But if there, if there was a movie made,
it would've been embraced.
By the same, by the same crowd that,
that it took in the first one.
'Cause they wanted to know what happened to the band,
what are you guys doing and all that kind of stuff.
And the story,
having some kind of a story that would've
been the whole catch.
Anyways. But the trailer was good.
Yeah. I caught a trailer.
The trailer was, the trailer was cool.
But this movie's coming out,
we're recording this in November.
It's coming out in the summer of 2022.
To coordinate with the "Anvil" album also being released.
I can't mention the title, but it's fantastic.
Well, I guess, I guess we could,
because by the time this.
(indistinct chatter)
So do you want Lips,
do you wanna say the Tide to the album?
Sure, the Anvil,
the new Anvil album is called "Impact is Imminent".
Of course it is, of course.
It's of course.
I've just seen the album artwork
and it features an "Anvil" as asteroid hurtling towards
the earth about to destroy it.
But for those Amble fans who haven't
had a chance to look it up,
I would suggest looking up the image online
of the album cover "Anvil" is "Anvil"
from a couple of years ago.
That's my favorite.
It's an Anvil,
an oil painting of an Anvil staring
at itself in the mirror.
It's called "Anvil Is Anvil".
And I called up Robb and I said,
"How fucking high were you
when you came up with this concept?"
And he said, "Pretty fucking high. Isn't it great?"
And I was like, Yes, it's great.
I mean, the whole point is, man, nothing changes.
You know, it's like these guys have been going
since the film and we have a new album
that will go inside with the re-release.
Beautiful man, I love you guys.
I'm so excited for you. And it's deserved, man.
It's so cool that this movie's getting
a new life with a new generation.
And you guys are just rocking all the way through it.
I mean, to see.
When Sacha said, "Hey man, you know,
the movie's gonna come back".
I said, "What are you talking about? Like really?
Come back?"
He goes, Yeah, it's gonna released
then it's gonna be, movie kind of thing.
Well, what kind of baffled? That never happens.
I said that.
It's kind of baffling you, you.
(indistinct chatter)
See the same movie again, but you don't want,
you don't want to see a new one?
Like, huh.
Well there'll be some extra stuff and you know,
it's, again, it's gonna be remastered, which is great.
But I mean the reason this is happening,
like I said, is because of the,
the young kids would see film and that's why we're doing it.
(indistinct) for this type of thing.
It's gonna be so cool.
We'll invite you to the premier, which will be around.
Yeah, of course.
'Cause the last one was not so bad, right?
No, that was fun.
And Sacha , I gotta say,
I mean you've been on the show before
and I've probably said this publicly,
but you had mentioned yes,
we've known each other for a long time
and I think over the 20 years of our friendship,
we've both gone through a lot.
And you have definitely been someone who's been there for me
during my low moments and difficult times.
And a lot of those times coincided with
when you were making this movie.
Like, I remember. Vividly.
A lot of time that we spent together.
I remember when you got married to Julie.
Dude, I was there that day.
I remember talking to you just before.
I remember that very well.
Do you remember that conversation?
Yes. Vividly.
Vividly.
It's been a while, man.
You know what, man? We're still here.
We're still fighting.
I know, I know.
I feel so lucky that've been invited onto this show
and to be able to share this, you know,
my really good friends.
Thank you very much.
(indistinct chatter)
Was an interesting chat.
It's an honor.
So if people wanna learn more about you guys, the band,
where do you wanna direct them?
Oh.
And obviously go see the movie.
Well, we have, what do we have?
You still have that?
We have the social media stuff.
You know, we have a Twitter,
we got an Instagram, we have a Facebook.
We got all the stuff.
They've got ll the stuff.
I think that right now, I like that
we're probably-
And actually we still,
we still have that rinky dinky.
They still have the rinky dink website.
(indistinct chatter)
The same one?
Yeah, yeah same one.
Virtually looks identical to what we did.
(indistinct chatter)
Since 1996.
Same fan site.
I'll link all that stuff up in the-
But it's so simple and so straightforward.
Everything is listed.
You'd click on it, brings it up and-
And are you guys touring now?
Yeah, well with COVID,
we had a huge tour last year with the legal or last record.
You know, the "Anvil" bong
people need to smoke the "Anvil" bong.
I guess they, don't they?
I mean that's really not much to say after.
But yeah, we were on, we were,
we had a great 65 date tour and we got 17 dates into the
tour and COVID just crushed, shut the word down.
So we've been, we did one live stream last year,
which was interesting.
We did that and we did one show a couple of weeks ago
just to be able to say we did a COVID gig.
That was kind of cool.
People are very hungry. It was great.
It was sold out, packed out.
Next year.
The UK tours just coming.
Yeah, we got big tour.
They're doing the biggest ever tour of the UK they've ever
done in 2022.
So it's just now we're at the mercy
of this COVID nonsense.
I mean like it's for real, but that they get it.
Just open the world up, you know, let's get on with it.
So that's complicated things.
In due time, but in the meantime,
great spend an afternoon with you guys.
Best of luck and I'll see you at the LA Premier.
Okay. Sounds good to me. Thank you. Thanks for having us.
Thank you Sacha .
Love you, man.
Love you too.
Peace.
(upbeat band music)